United
read ladies and gentlemen as chair of
the labor
Industrial Services
as
thise
[Music]
toate
platform necessarily access information
have been made available in the house
us
HCS
today
representative infantine I apologize to
interrupting but we're not able to hear
um
anything if I may it's it's it's very
garbled like there's some sort of
interference well like he's
yeah maybe that's gargled instead of
yeah
out uh if you could keep talking that
microphone
end are these tabletop microphones
working that's definitely better we can
saying
perhaps oh no we can't hear you um I've
I just went over um I sent a message to
I yeah it seems like the I can see any
other noise it picks it up
yes I can hear you representative
talking without the
microphone I've got one right in front
is
on
this
[Music]
small
you can you um are you able to restart
the
computer
H the problem is it will pick up the
speaked
and
go I'm sorry I can't hear you um if we
were thinking if you reboot the computer
TV and then once you connect to
zoom I can get you the
least
for
okay
youed
MI
through the
that
there
now
that
to
than
[Music]
see
it
[Music]
she
garbled
uh will I I think as I recall last time
you had to switch to you using your
audio well this is an issue with the the
committee
room
[Music]
yeah you know what we need to do is get
commissioner marfield in here I'm sure
he knows his
[Music]
audio 23
justr it sounds very loud um on one end
so we can hear but it's it's it's very
um
I don't have a u i can't speak can't
email just
just that is a little bit better still a
little noisy though at the end it sounds
like you're
um I don't know it's very very loud at
the
end I just got a text saying it might be
a bad cable for the chairman to switch
microphone I couldn't hear anything you
they
had they had that problem with the DNA
cable that's what get to that yeah but
off
vibr
[Music]
fuzzyen it seems like
it's something in that microphone
probably not even the microphone
itself yeah
clearly PL that in if it's the same
want plug in one of these other cords to
see if it's this
system
[Music]
hey guys are picking up the sound the
getting
working it's not getting from this sound
board to there the happen with us and
you can't access through the computer
Mastermind
you you have time I wish I could
somehow but
the are working well and I can hear I
when you talk directly into that or I
Zo can Christina hear
us I can hear you um when you're not
talking into the
off want to that put the side put on
[Music]
thanks the audio is going in and out so
we can hear the room sometimes and then
it disappears for a little while and
back
Christina may make a suggestion labor is
BR
sure
um following it from the beginning when
they started opening the zoom individual
Zooms in the room the microphone started
to get worse so would I make a
suggestion to have everybody that is
not the main computer to log out of zoom
[Music]
interference I think probably the room
heard
you
this
f
for
okay um Joshua Josh do you have a phone
number for Don Bard by any chance he I'm
getting an email from Heather that Don
buchard is still waiting for a logging
information
got on he came on a little late and he
said oh I finally got on he's very
loud
right
don't
[Music]
um sorry I just accidentally muted the
labor room um I meant to unmute myself
the audio is still coming in and out so
while we can hear you while you're
talking it will
stop
um and then we can't hear anything and
in okay I'm sorry I can I muted the uh
no we can't hear you I can hear some
static in the background I know you're
talking for that reason but I can't hear
any
words
something I have any experience in so
iate one two three Christina is that any
better uh no same issue it's very fuzzy
while we can hear your words uh it
now
[Music]
Christina yes I can hear
you yes I'm speaking into the table
lovely
from
there she she said that I I'm coming all
the
way yes I can hear you for the most part
representative
seaworth Dina I'm speaking through the
Des microphone as well can you hear this
I can hear most of what you're saying
nowon
comp
to
[Music]
for
e
any the table
[Music]
teacher
yes that was a little better at the end
clearly I don't think that was the only
thing I said
but well I heard you pretty clearly
right
there head chair infantine I I don't
know what it is but I can't hear you at
you're
speaker please all right we're gonna try
microphones
okay
why don't you
try taking the
microphone over there and so you can go
cord all in the room work yeah but she
can hear me fine on this and not in on
two3 two3 Christina can you hear me yes
there okay
Christina that sounds that sounds great
talking give you two minutes to get back
on here
two three one two three okay if you were
a little bit louder uh if the volume was
up a little bit louder I think we could
hear you fine all right we're gonna try
now you been to a concert test test one
okay
I'm gy my computer here to so I
Zoom all right perfect although um again
you're a little bit quiet so you might
just have
to either turn the volume up or just be
a little bit louder but we can hear the
words you're saying all right I would
like you to as I continue talking
they're going to be playing with the
volume let we know if it gets better as
I continue to
talk
again am I still coming through yes we
can hear you
fine
really you might have to give up your
chair representative
[Laughter]
seaworth
anything
it's not great um I can it sounds like
they
you hear
me no no I mean I can hear you very
faintly but not the clear
words
me
excuse me your name hey Scott what if we
have turned off you can me people having
time
right if everyone mind turning off their
their zooms if they have it on
here
that no didn't hear anything
afterwards
words
one two three one two
three I can hear
words you can't hear
garbled and now we've lost audio just
out
Sy
see
[Music]
anything I don't hear any words only I
words you wouldn't really be able to see
hear
is
compter
thank
you
just
like
[Music]
here
reason thank
password
of
do
get
reason
hybrid to the
computer
they
did
same
water
situ
it's
better
yeah
thinking so you can hear is if we do if
listen
that's
it
time
Christina
yes could we ask the chairman to turn
off his Zoom feed maybe that will help
device he can hear
you okay sometimes the depending on the
interference
that
just
think
actually he's
not
CHR chrisa
you I can hear my name but that's all I
anybody
to
[Music]
I'm
so
Happ
what
got
e
that
here
[Music]
minut
little
[Music]
so
myself my computer could you try
to set me up here as
okay can you hear me
Christina can you hear me not let's try
not on the telephone okay can you hear
me not on the telephone
Christina is that a
yes I I can hear you I can hear hear you
clearly yeah if you could put me on the
computer here so I can see
everybody yeah we can hear you
good but and what I think what you have
to do is go
to um she has right now it's you've got
it set up to focus on the speaker and
you've gotta change it to Gallery
VI
there okay if you would give me your
thumbs up on all
right so this is what we're
doing I I muted
the
computer maybe we can turn that down so
we don't hear as much we do have a
little bit of a
wonder
right we'll just have to be very
slow um would
someone repr would you unmute and I'd
like to hear you speak to
me see how it comes through testing
Frozen thank
you thank you what I'm going to
DeLay So after you hear me speak if I do
speak wait a few seconds before you
speak
back all right Christina I'm gonna start
again and we're going to see how we do
bad habit attendance I'm going to read
attendance you should be able to hear
through this or speak of
disclaimer as chair of the labor
industrial and rehabilitation service
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the ID 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
all
um do you think we should just do this
whole thing remotely and abandon the L
for
now
all right folks uh I got bounced off and
I just don't know whether or not I
should continue into the hearing and
then uh continue to be bounced off if it
happens again so I want to continue
reading or start reading the script
again and if it does bounce us off
um I don't know I might have to uh
uh Christina before I continue do we
have do we still have four
individuals waiting to testify on House
Bill
385 representative uh Warner or horn
excuse
them I see
participants have we
attendance have we taken attendance
yet no
as chair of the labor industrial and
I we
did no I have to read the script first
and since you couldn't hear it the first
time I was going to read it again if you
feel I've already everyone's already
attendance
seeing no complaint I'm going to read
again as chair of the labor industrial
and rehabilitative services committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as resolve coid
19 pandemic and in accordance with rule
67 the governor's emergency order
pursuant number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I'm confirming that all members of
the committee and selective legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contempor contemporaneously during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in the meeting
by Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available to the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar of the
general court website this notice of
this meeting notice complies with house
rule RSA 9
1A anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS ledge. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to acess access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
Christina Dyer is the staff assisting us
please note all votes that are taken
during the meeting shall be done by roll
call vote let's start by taking the roll
call attendance each member states their
presence please all also St whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
Clerk
go
here in the room with everyone here in
the
L
seaworth you're in the
room
[Music]
youum myself in the
room
who
[Music]
work unfortunately folks this is not
going to work we have a uh 10 second
delay uh we we're speaking I'm trying to
not hear what I'm hearing myself say
we're trying to take
attendance um and uh we can't hear you
15 seconds later someone might say yes
uh I'm gonna go Scout around see what I
can uh get us fixed
up
reconvene
um
Christina I believe he's looking to
um at one o' but I'm going to verify
before we go anywhere I I just had a
thought like what if we all left and
meeting maybe it's a zoom issue today
it's what it's working in in the other
committee rooms oh okay um so I think he
wants to reconvene at one o'clock let me
just verify before anybody
goes when I logged in this morning to
zoom it uh it took forever so I had to
uh shut down my computer start up and
use a different uh issue of Zoom Zoom I
guess and which is fine so it's
certainly possible that what's happening
connection
should
it wasn't clear to me um whether will
was ready
to uh
stop the meeting and and start again at
one I think he wanted to check for some
uh representative infantine is going to
try to resume uh in about 20 minutes
with another computer to see if we can
work through and uh if everybody could
just hold tight or just come back and 15
20 minutes uh we'll see what we can do
started
right
I'm
leaving
stand
that
and
yeah
so do you have to understand how all
that stuff works so when you have a
problem you can understand
now
overview do from the Christina can you
hear us yes absolutely
picture can you hear me
Christina yes I can you're a little um
it's a little loud but I can I can make
out every
word please talk
Sly that's not that better that's not
much better but we can still hear
loud yes Christina is this too loud
actually that's that's fine we can hear
you okay
business checking the table mic now is
is the volume good on this one it's
perfect we can hear you all
perfectly
okay having read the so you announced
we'd be a we'd start after 20 minutes
yeah I know try to get everyone back on
um
thank you thank you please if anyone has
thank you uh Scott if anyone has a cell
phone number of your fellow
members um might want to call someone
try to get them back I know I said 20
minutes and it's only been 10 um see if
we can get people oh representative
Sullivan he's having he's having his
early lunch nice
nice um I'll call loo or something
someone called Ben Mark Warden come on
Mark see if I can get
Mark I'm present Mr
chairman I'll text Ben and Linda okay
here if anyone's here you want to put
the I'm here cameras back on here I
Mark
here uh cameras are off I just want to
see here who is here representative D
sylvestro are you with
us I just texted her okay representative
aini aani all right hey buddy Mr
here Linda was on a phone call a minute
ago I'm going to look on the
participants and see who I got
here thank you
markusi Ben
Rudy buard Len
turot
panelists see what we got for panelists
okay
attendees okay I see all you folks on
there Curtis bury uh Dave juv uh Heather
that's Heather goalie Heather are plants
doing well since I gave it water um John
mallister we're going to try to get you
guys on here and up and
moving uh very quickly here gota wait
for a few more people to come on so I
attendance I don't need a corner I can
to
[Music]
I'm gonna open
up hey guys I'm going to open up the
original hearing and then I'm going to
suspend it and then I'm going to go to
the 10:00 hearing for those people are
all that are waiting I think that'd be
the best thing since the firefighters is
only four of them and they said they
like to come back at 1 so I can always
have them quickly at
1 that's
all right everybody so we're going to
start off I'm going to open 385 then I'm
going to uh post suspend it
um yeah suspend that's that's not the
right word continue what's the
word
us I'm going to reset that and I'm going
to open up uh 590 because there are a
number of people uh a lot of people so
we can spend you know an hour or so um
the first one was supposed to go from 9
to 10 this is 10 10 to 12 so we're only
45 minutes late so that's what I'm going
here Mr clerk would you mind calling the
rooll yes
please infantine here I'm in the
L see where Earth present in the room
avalani at work employees around not
alone and
present
C here in the room myself in the room
Nunez present in the
room
Warden I am here my um home office with
nobody else
here chot here in the Committee hearing
room
Pro he will have be
here he called me was be to make it Boyd
here in the room H here in the room
Sullivan here in my home office
alone
Susy here at home by
myself
Bui uh here in my home office my
assistant here she'll be leaving in 20
minutes
attend
vro
Schmid I'm here in nesa um in my home
office
alone
Tumi here in my home office uh
Don that's okay I can read lips Don rard
is here in his office no I'm here at
home and
thank you Mr
clerk Representatives this is what I
would like to do I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill 385 FN it is open
I am now going to recess that until 1:00
uh I have any
communication um on the telephone with
the lobbyist and she has confirmed that
they are unable to meet right now some
of them are getting their second coid
uh shots so we're not going to interrupt
that and we're going to have them join
us at 1:00 so we're going to recess
House Bill 385 FN until 1 I'm now going
to take up House Bill 590 FN relative to
paid sick time unfortunately
um you know things being what they are I
thought we're going to have
representative kahill but I guess we're
not we're going to
[Music]
recognize
here my apologies I got my papers all
messed up representative walner is the
my uh representative infantine we do
have um representative kahill joining us
thank you I do not have a representative
here on my signin sheet so
representative Sullivan the prime
sponsor is representative walner as you
us I do not see
her
just
and
on Zoom we cannot hear anything uh
representative infantine I do have
representative alt Sher who is also
um on the bill as well as rep
representative Schultz representative
walner has raised her hand as
well oh there she is okay uh it appears
that
White
so it looks like everybody um in the
office building in the lb
was uh booted off the system so I know
that representative infantine is going
to try and get back on um so we will
difficulties
Christina can you hear yes okay would
you please put the screen back to where
it needs to be and we're going to
online not many right now okay as
members come
online with your videos please give me a
thumbs up if you can hear hear me okay
it looks like everyone can hear me all
right the the internet system in the
building went down so for anyone who was
listening in there was no hearing that
was going on uh we suspended as soon as
the system went down the only thing that
we have done and I would like a thumbs
up if everyone did hear representative
seaworth did introduce House Bill 590 I
didn't you didn't yeah start okay I
would uh okay I would call
Representative infantine we do actually
have um representative
walner
excellent all right representative
walner thank you for your patience and
coming back on you recognized to
590 okay can I'm unmuted I believe
you're fine
can
you okay good thanks um uh thank you
chairman infantine and members of the
labor committee and thank you all for
your your great patience and for um how
you've all waited waited to get this U
challenge you want any kind of speaker
if you could we're having very difficult
time hearing you uh at least in the room
here it's very muffled if you could
speak either into the receiver or maybe
if you're not on a a a speaker um and a
little louder so we can all hear you go
ahead I thank you I apologize for the
interruption okay can you hear me better
now yes is it better now okay I just
moved it much closer to me um and thank
you again for um holding the hearing and
for for working out the technology
problems
um my name is Mary Jane walner I'm a
state representative from conquered I
represent conquered Ward five and
hopkington House Bill 590 is a bill that
requires employers to provide employees
the opportunity to earn a minimum amount
of paid sick
time according to research before the
pandemic in
2018 by a New Hampshire researcher Dr
Kristen Smith who is at Dartmouth now
and at the time was at the Cary School
of public policy at the University of
New Hampshire 32% of working people in
New Hampshire do not have access to a
single paid sick
[Music]
day close to onethird of the people
working in New Hampshire have no sick
pay time
off the people least likely to have
access sorry about the clock the people
least likely to have access to paid
sitime work work part-time and for lower
than average wages women particularly
mothers and people with family members
with disabilities are less likely to
have access to earn paid
time this bill would ensure people who
are employed in New Hampshire earn at
least one hour of paid sick time for
every 30 hours they
work the maximum time anyone would be
guaranteed in a year would be 72
hours the bill would not impact anyone
currently offering an equivalent or more
generous amounts of paid time off that
can be used for qualifying res reasons
which include one's own sickness injury
need for medical d diagnosis or
preventive care or that of a family
members as defined by the statute it
would also enable the sick time to be
used for absences necessary due to
sexual assault or domestic violence and
for public health emergencies related to
closures the bill would also ensure
working people are protected from
off I would guess one of the concerns
you'll hear is about whether or not it's
our business to have any say in what
employers offer for
benefits when we leave it up to
businesses we end up with working people
least likely to be able to afford
missing a day's wages least likely to
have paid time
off we need to set a minimum floor to
ensure all working people have some
ability to take time to care for
themselves or their family when they are
sick if we've learned anything from the
pandemic it's that it's the public in
the Public's best interest for people
who are sick to stay
home and it is in the Public's best
interest for children who are sick to be
able to stay home from school or child
care in order to limit the spread of
contagious disease I ran a child care
agencies for Agency for 45 years and
that gave me an upfront um and close
look at what happens when people don't
have access to paid sick days they go to
work sick and that means that they drop
their children off sick at child care or
at
school nobody wants to send a sick child
to school they do it because they have
to because they can't make ends meet if
they miss a day of work
work this bill will make sure no one has
to choose between a day's pay and
staying home when they or their children
are sick thank you Mr um chair and I'll
take questions if there are
any thank you
representative any questions from any of
the committee members online I see
representative
buard um thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you representative walner for taking my
question I represent Manchester and in
Manchester there are an awful lot of
small
businesses my question is to
you
um how will this bill benefit small
you um thank you uh representative bard
well I think you know there are a number
of ways that businesses will also um
benefit from having a minimum amount of
sick time available to their employees
um as an employer myself for I 45 years
I I know that um I it was when someone
came to work who was
sick other people then were sick and
then I would end up with an issue where
I would have my Workforce I'd have a lot
of my workforce out so the benefit for
people to be able to not come in sick
and not spread the not spread contagious
disease is obviously very important I
also think it's really good for
retention of employees I think when
employees are looking for work they're
looking for obviously the best wage they
can find they're looking for good
working conditions and having at least a
minimum amount of sick time available I
employees thank
you any other questions on Zoom please I
don't see any yellow hands anyone want
to physically raise their hand I'll call
on you seeing none are there any
questions of the committee members here
in the
L representative H H you're uh
recognized
thank you Mr Speaker um my question
is
will the question was um uh if you
could
over what will do
for selfy what will this do for selfy
hear I'm I'm sorry I did notar hear the
now
yes my my question was what will this do
people well I don't think that it will
it will affect um self-employed people I
think that self-employed people um end
up having to make their own decisions
about um
their ability to work when they are um
maybe when they are not feeling feeling
well and um they have to write that into
sort of their business plan uh there
would probably be there this would not
you seeing no other questions thank you
representative uh I would call the next
representative uh welcome
Deborah aler representative uh
Rockingham 19 representative are you
with
us yes I am thank you very much can you
hear me clearly yes very clearly thank
you
wonderful thank you committee members
for your time and for your service and
for your patience with this morning's
technical difficulties I'm very very
glad to be with you today as a
co-sponsor of house Bill 590 I wish to
draw your attention to the safe leave
aspect of the bill which enables the
program to be used for the needs of
people who experienced sexual assault or
domestic violence in section seven part
275 I semicolon 9 which you can see on
page
printed I'll give you just a
minute
could you please repeat the section
representative four it's on page
seven no I'm sorry page six page six
line
seven my
bad and it's section 275 dasi semicolon
9 confidential and non-disclosure no
employer shall require disclosure of
details relating to domestic violence
sexual assault or stalking or the
details of an employes medical condition
as a condition of being provided paid
sick time under this chapter If an
employer possesses health information or
information pertaining to domestic
violence sexual assault or stalking
about an employee or an employees family
member such information shall be treated
as confidential and not disclosed except
to the affected employee or with the
permission of the affected
employee and so I point that out because
I it it's important to reme to um I want
to draw attention to the people who
would benefit so very very greatly from
the opportunity to use paid sick time to
deal with these issues paid sick and
safe days would protect the paychecks of
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault or stalking when they need to
take time off from their jobs to get
medical care support services enact a
safety plan to get away from their
perpetrator and if they choose go to
court Seeking Justice in my work for the
last nine years as a volunteer advocate
for one of New Hampshire's crisis
response Cent centers I've been to the
hospital emergency departments dozens of
times to to support survivors of sexual
assault the first time a Survivor told
me they had to go to work right after
their forensic medical exam was
complete and that they had been
administered a powerful cocktail of
prophylactic drugs to ad address
possible exposures to sexually
transmitted infections I was crushed for
them just shook that they were not
able to take that time off after such a
traumatic event because they couldn't
afford to lose the paycheck many of my
fellow Advocates have accompanied
survivors to court where they're
applying for restraining orders against
their
abusers Advocates are frustrated for
their clients seeing them check their
watches while they're sitting in court
waiting to be called knowing that those
survivors can't afford to miss a work
shift no no matter how how far behind
the courts
run data from the national violence
against women survey published by the
Centers for Disease Control estimates
that women in the United States lose
almost 8 million days of paid work each
year because of interpersonal violence
survivors in New Hampshire who are
employed in jobs with no benefits and
unforgiving leave policies feel the tide
pulling them under as they struggle to
cope with an abusive household
maintaining employment is often the
Lynch pin in attaining Financial
stability needed to keep a family in
crisis steady and self-sufficient while
recovering from abuse no victim in New
Hampshire should have to choose between
losing a paycheck or going to the
hospital for a sexual assault
examination and a forensic medical
evidence collection no victim in New
Hampshire should have to choose between
losing a paycheck or a court date to get
a restraining order against their abuser
no victim in New Hampshire should have
to choose between losing a paycheck and
meeting with a family violence
prevention SP specialist from a crisis
center who's helping them build a safety
plan and access to life-saving support
services I urge you to keep the
thousands of survivors of sexual assault
domestic violence and stalking in mind
as you weigh the benefits of paid sick
time for the hardworking citizens of New
Hampshire and I thank you for your time
this morning
thank you representative any
Zoom seeing none any in the committee
room representative this is will
infantine I do have a question for you
um in reading this bill obviously is
there things I like and don't like but I
really did like section on page six
section 9 through 15 or 9 through 14 or
regarding um domestic violence sexual
assault or stalking and the question I
have for you is
just how does this work um how do
you tell your employer you have a
situation like this
without having to tell your employer you
have a situation like
this well actually I'm I'm really glad
you asked that question thank you um
because you know ideally you don't don't
and the idea is that paid sick time
you've earned that paid sick time or
safe time and you can use it exactly for
those purposes now we do have
Protections in New Hampshire that um if
a Survivor discloses to their employer
they cannot be retaliated against um and
they they have to be um accommodated for
instance if a perpetrator is uh stalking
their
their victim at work um of an employer
cannot fire that
employee for being a victim of stalking
so we have those Protections in place
and the reason we have um this space in
and on page five and you're looking at
employee
records that when an employee does
disclose to an employer that they're
having this is their issue um just as an
employee might disclose to their
employer that they need to take medical
time off but they may not disclose all
the details like I may need to tell you
I need to take some medical time but I'm
not going to give you the details of my
cancer diagnosis um I would tell you
that I need to take time off because I'm
experiencing um some interpersonal
violence I might say domestic violence I
might say I was the victim of sexual
assault but then I've now put you in the
position of having to keep that
confidential and I might not want to
have to do that to you um so there's a
little bit of flexibility in there in
that um employees May
disclose but they don't have to give you
all of the details does that make sense
it does thank you okay like I might want
not want to go through all of the
specifics of my abuse just to tell you
that I've experienced this and I need to
take this time because I'm going to
court or I have to go to the
hospital thank you representative I
don't see any additional questions thank
you for the
question you're welcome thank you uh the
next uh speaker is representative Chris
us
yes Mr chair can you hear me can hear
you very well thank you go ahead great
great thank you um I am tempted to um
tell stories from constituents uh I
represent a part of conquer that has a
number of people who earn low wages work
at the big box stores at the grocery
store service industry Etc instead I
would like to suggest we think of this
topic for selfish reasons and I'm G to
flip the script on some actual stories
that I have heard from workers in our
community so imagine you're at a
restaurant and you order a hamburger and
the worker has the flu or you go to
Dunkin' donuts and the cashier has a
cold or your mother has is elderly and
is recovering from surgery and is able
to do it more affordably from home but
their care Aid has the
flu or you go to deas to buy groceries
and the produce stalker has another
colder flu something that you can catch
all of these are true firstperson
stories but the point I'm making
is all of the F the largest percentage
of folks who don't get paid sick leave
actually handle our food work in the
service industry our home care aids or
work in child care centers these are
Frontline workers that during the coid
crisis they've received lots of
gratitude um but if they can't afford to
stay home when they're sick or in the
case of the story about the Home Care
Aid she was Point Blank told by her boss
there is no one to replace you this
person you need to care for would be by
herself you have to report to your job
or you'll be fired in each and every one
of these cases it puts us a
risk uh
individually for the lack of paid sick
leave um buy I think it's about 40% of
the workforce in New Hampshire doesn't
have paid sick leave and again the
majority of those folks are people who
are in Frontline industry jobs often
either handling our food or in some way
shape or form caring for others and uh
you know so I would suggest these are
very good reasons to want paid sickly
for
others um and I know because of your
technical
difficulties you will appreciate that
testimony I'm happy to take questions
Zoom I don't see any questions any
questions of the representative from
here in the
lob seeing none thank you representative
thank you Mr
chair call
Representative sfia
wer from
doesn't
say
Sophia yes good morning Mr chair can you
hear me yes representative we can hear
you well thank you thank you thank you
Mr chair and member of the committee my
name is Sophia wazir representing from
maram 17 in conquer I'm speaking today
in favor of house Phill 59 FN relative
to pic
time this time we are in has sh us how
contagious viruses can be and the sad
consequences of passing our illness onto
others especially those who are elderly
or more vulnerable than
ourselves coid 19 provides a dramatic
view of this bill but even in typical
times the flu and other illnesses can be
transmitted including by those who go to
work sick
those who do not have paid sick days
often choose to go to work ill because
they count on the money they earn to buy
Essentials to buy groceries to pay rent
and to support their
families I appreciate the way that this
bill provides fair treatment to
part-time as well as fulltime
employees illness does not distinguish
between those who work 20 hours out of a
job and those who work 40
hours throughout my life I worked many
part-time jobs I worked two part-time
jobs at a time one working nearly
full-time hours I interacted with many
customers and clients in those
positions and yet I didn't qualify for
sick time being paid hourly I would not
be paid if I did not show up to work and
I might be looked at unfavor if I stayed
home to get well I really missed a
workday for those
reasons those
days contagious viruses are greatly on
our minds for our good reasons however
one time after a serious injury I went
back to work almost immediately because
I could not afford to stay home and I
apologize for the background noise
as the mother of three children I am
pleased to see that this bill allows
sick time to be used as a cur for family
members Medical Care those moms and dads
who work at a lowi income and part-time
jobs who do not earn sick time may need
this time for sick child or their
child's medical
appointment I have seen parents have to
take child from from conquer to Children
Hospital at
Dartmouth in Lebanon to see The
Specialist and that can be not just a
Tre tremendous worry but an all day
event they shouldn't have to worry about
lost wages on top of the medical
bills this bill allows Fair a Cel of
sick time off and yes coid 19 is the
most example of this the STA the states
surrounding surrounding us have already
seen the wisdom of page time and enacted
bills it's time for New Hampshire to do
this too and I hope you will support
House Bill 590 FN and thank you so much
Mr chair thank you representative do you
have any questions on Zoom for uh the
committee seeing none anyone um in the
committee
room there are no questions for you
thank you
representative thank than you all right
I have 18 folks ready to speak here
hopefully you'll be here if not we'll
give you a couple seconds after we
introduce you to to take yourself off
mute a number of you have uh signed in
to speak and said you need zero minutes
to speak so I don't know what that means
but we'll find out so the first person
on my list Ted
Janowski member of the public sir uh if
you're on the line you're recognized yes
I see your face go ahead go ahead
represent go ahead sir
yes uh my name is Ted Janowski from
forsmith New Hampshire and I'm here to
speak in favor of Hospital 590 you know
this same measure passed in
Massachusetts just a few years ago uh
and I actually worked with friends in
Massachusetts on some of the technical
aspects of the bill down there they've
since done studies and they've not seen
any negative economic effects because of
the passage of a p sick we bill down
there but I'd like to speak to one point
in particular that I think is really
important here from personal experience
that paid sick days reduce employee
turnover uh I I took over a job in
Boston once as the president of the
Greater Boston real estate they had a
lot of problems uh one of the bigest
problems they had was tremendous amount
of uh employee turnover and a lot of
their positions are highly trained
specific ones for different duties and
it takes you months to train someone so
I was really interested in why was this
level of turnover so high and a lot of
it was the lower ranks in terms of pay
so I took it upon myself to do my own
research I contacted every employee over
the from the three-year period prior to
my taking on the job and spoke to them
and asked why did you leave was it n
okay was a not enough opportunity up and
I was so surprised that about a third of
the employees that had left in their
previous period cited the fact that they
didn't have paid si le and they switched
to a job that gave them paid sick leave
because they were dragging themselves to
work or didn't have the opportunity in
particular to care for their children
when they became sick and that was the
bigger is biggest issue so I went went
to my board very very conservative board
to say the least put the numbers
together and showed that we could
actually save money if we didn't have
such high rates of turnover if we could
just reduce it by that minimal amount we
would be saving money in the long term
more behold very next budget year we
went in and we showed that we had less
turnover it actually was saving us money
in terms of training and things of that
thank you very much members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
you thank thank you any questions um
from the commit committee members
online don't see any any from the
committee seeing none thank you
sir thank you like to
call I have Deborah Nelson and I have
Deb Nelson looks like it's the same one
so uh Deborah Nelson
please yes thank you it is the same
person I assume you can hear me is that
correct yes we can thank you uh I really
appreciate Mr chairman and members of
the Comm of the committee that you're
giving me this chance to speak with you
about the importance of providing sick
leave to all employees in our state and
I would like to share my own experience
of having to use thck time when I
herniated a disc in my back as I'm sure
you all realize it happened suddenly
without time to plan and I was
immediately in such excruciating pain
that I was sick to my stomach I was at a
restaurant having dinner with friends
and I had to leave immediately although
I wasn't sure that I would be able to
manage driving the short distance to my
house I couldn't stand or sit
comfortably and the pain was so intense
I honestly couldn't think about anything
other than the pain fortunately at the
time
I'm now retired I was a public school
teacher and I had sick time negotiated
in my contract and I needed it I needed
it both for the following couple of days
until the intensity of the pain subsided
and I needed it for my recovery after
surgery and I was always profoundly
aware of my privilege in being able to
take time off I speak to you this
morning about all those who don't have
sick time who cannot be at home with an
ill child or care for an ill parent or
recover from surgery or illness without
losing P I know every single one of us
has had that experience of sudden
illness that prompts us to spend some
time on the floor of a
bathroom and I want you to consider as
was earlier mentioned those individuals
who still must somehow show up for their
work I know I'm not alone in finding it
horrifying to consider that someone with
the flu might be preparing or serving a
meal I plan to eat I know I'm not alone
in wanting the people who work in retail
or at the grocery store or in
restaurants or in any number of small
businesses to know that they can and
should stay home when they're contagious
I think also of those caring for
children or a spouse or parents who've
been hospitalized who are dying who are
in need of care and the struggles of
these individuals have been made
profoundly clear during the pandemic War
experience those of us with good
benefits those of us with negotiated
contracts those of us who are privileged
when it comes to being ill are not the
ones we're talking about today your job
is to govern I hope for the benefit of
many not for the few and so I ask you to
consider the greater good as you prepare
to support and vote Yes on this Bill
thank you very
speaker seeing none in the L seeing none
online thank you very much thank
you uh I'm gonna call um Val Zan cook
and Rosie Garvey will be after just so
you can get ready Val zook are you with
us sand
cook from graphic cast
Inc
there Val okay yeah I am here F I didn't
realize my mute button came up thank you
Mr chair members of the committee uh for
the record my name is Val zanchuck I'm
president of graphic has which is a
Manufacturing Company in Jaffrey New
Hampshire uh for the record I am also
the past chair of the Bia but I am not
speaking on behalf of the Bia today as
president of a company twice named as a
top 10 company to work for in New
Hampshire and one which currently
provides paid time off to our employees
I am not at all opposed to the concept
of paytime offer paid sick time I think
company policies and benefits should be
constructed to remove or reduce family
stress so that employees can focus on
the work for which they are paid these
benefits provide financial and emotional
support to our employees they also
improve the productivity and
profitability of our company paid
benefits I think make good economic
sense to the individual to the company
and to our
society however I oppose this bill as
written because I feel there's an
overbearing prescriptive nature uh
included in this bill on how paid sick
leave or paid sick time off is to be
allocated and managed each company has
its own history and culture these
provide the basis for company policies
and philosophies that make a particular
company an attractive place to work the
company's Financial conditions also
impact its ability to provide benefits
the combination of all these factors
allows companies to craft benefit
packages that balance employee needs
with company
resources this bill intends to create a
highly prescriptive set of rules that
strip companies of their ability to
create policy that make sense for them
and their employees these prescriptions
do not take into account company
finances employee demographics company
attendance policies local cultural norms
owner philosophies company operations
and everything else that goes into
developing workable policies I also feel
they don't take into account human
nature as anyone who owns or runs a
business will
confirm legislating that companies
should have paid sick leave May gain
some support in the business Community
as this is a policy already in place
with many employers however dictating
how to implement and how to manage paid
sick leave will gain no support from the
much thank you for your comments any
questions for the speaker representative
kahill you're recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Mr vanchu for taking my question I I
understand from you know I I read your
uh letter and I heard your testimony I
understand that you uh you agreed with
the previous speaker that this is a good
policy to have uh offering paid sick
time it makes economic sense it's good
for your
retention um and and yet there we
learned that there are 30 some 30% of uh
employees that don't have it and how are
we to how are we to uh remedy this if we
don't as you say prescribe uh rules
minimum rules at that but do something
so that they will have some opportunity
to address these situations as they
arise well you know in reading through
the the the bill I mean the the
prescriptions are so specific as to make
every company have almost exactly the
same rules and when you've got tens of
thousands of individual Employers in the
state each with their own set of
circumstances and
workforces uh you just can't have a
blanket policy that fits all the
circumstances that each of those
companies have whether it's U you know
the the uh they their financial
resources for example or uh whether or
not as like in our case we operate
multiple shifts uh we have a mix of
different types of people on the floor I
mean all these things are things that we
we spend a lot of time uh taking into
consideration when we develop our our
benefits packages and they're they're
specific to our needs and specific to um
you know what we can afford to do and
how what makes sense for us and our
employees to get the best benefit for
everyone having a whole list of what we
have to do without taking any of that
into consideration just creates a
disastrous situation for many many
companies I think if you say you know
our our our feeling is that there should
be paid uh sick leave and it should be
you know u x percent of you know of um
you know X number of days per year or
something and then leave it at that
don't tell us how to put that together
because you can't know what is involved
in running my company to be able to tell
me from you know the other side of the
state that this is how I should run my
company I have a better sense of my
employees and their needs and their
capabilities and I've already decided
you know decades ago that this is this
is something that's of benefit to us and
we've evolved that policy over years as
our Workforce has changed as
circumstances have changed uh you know
this this legislation would would would
restrict us uh with with many directives
about how many days should be allocated
how they recruit how they should I I
don't think that's the the role of you
know the legislature or government to
tell us specifically you know especially
a private company exactly how to run
every aspect of its
business saying that as a society having
paid six leave is something that's a
benefit to society is one thing and I
agree with that what I don't agree with
is you telling me how to run my program
for my business without knowing the
things that I know and the things that
we have to deal with to make that policy
effective follow up Mr chairman follow
up thank you sir uh you in the bill
there's language that if if your company
meets or exceeds you know what we what
the minimum we require you're all set
it's not going to be that you have to
match it it's just that you know you
have to be that that as a minimum well
you're you're suggesting a certain uh uh
AC croval rate um which I think is again
uh something that is is something that
we should be able to determine based on
how our company operates uh you're you
know I think the suggestion is something
like 12 days a year uh you know we got
away from paid sick days and went to pay
time off to give our employees more
flexibility and how to choose the time
so and we also have shortterm disability
in place so within five days that
short-term disability kicks in so
they're not using their sick time and
they have another mechanism to support
themselves you know these are all things
that we evolve over time and again I
don't think there's there's anything
wrong with the concept of of paid uh
sick leave or paid time off I just don't
appreciate someone who has no knowledge
of what we do or whatever thousands of
other companies do telling us exactly
how that policy should be you don't tell
us what our wages should be you don't
tell us you know what our vacation
policies should be um you know we're
private companies we can determine what
we want to do uh we're not violating any
law we're free to choose that if the
employees don't like what we're offering
they don't have to work here if they do
like what we're offering they're going
to come in in in in droves uh I mean
that's the nature of the of the free
free market uh not only for businesses
but for Labor uh so I don't I don't
think you know prescribing very specific
uh benefits is is really the direction
we should be going saying as a society
we should have certain benefits because
they benefit Society is one thing but
then leave it leave it to everyone to to
work out the way that makes the most
sense for
them thank you I appreciate your
testimony thank you
repres representative
Adon thank you Mr chairman um can
everybody hear me
y um I wanted to follow up on uh
something you said in your first answer
um you made a com comment something
similar to uh if you want to tell us how
many days uh we're required to provide
uh paid sick leave for uh then that's a
different thing but don't tell us
specifically how to do that um what do
you think is a reasonable number of days
that the state should uh ensure the
employees have access to paid
leave well when we had specific paid
sick leave um and I think it was fairly
common
in the in the area we had three three
days per year and it it accured um you
know a certain number of hours uh you
know per per hour work or per per week
um but what we found was that we were
really operating with two systems a a
sick leave system and a vacation system
and sometimes those things would be in
in conflict with each other so um in in
consultation with a number of other
companies as to where they were evolving
um they went to a a paid time off where
there's a pool of days that are
available to be used as the employee
wishes so what we did is we took our our
our typical uh vacation acral system
which is based on years of service and
we added our our three days of uh of
sick leave to that pool and we added um
an extra day that people got and made
the whole pool available which gives the
employee a great deal of um control over
how and when they use those days so
there there is right now no level of of
sick days there's there's a level of of
PTO so um depending on the the
circumstances uh you know an employee
could take five days of of PTO for an
illness uh or you know two or three days
uh it gives them the opportunity to
manage that and it also uh eliminates
the the the situation where you have
people needing a sick day uh but not
having any of the the sick days left and
then calling in sick and taking it as an
unpaid day when in the PTO system they
could just use it as PTO so we felt this
was a a better system for the employees
to be able to manage their time and in
in all cases uh you if an employee knows
they're going to be out for you know
going to the hospital with a with a sick
child or something like that as long as
they give us uh you know notice ahead of
time then they can take their their PTO
and it's it's already planned and and
buil into the schedule and and nobody
suffers so I think PTO is a better
system but when we were on paid sick
leave we uh we went with three days and
and that seemed to be the norm uh in
this
area you have a followup question yes
Uhn if you if you'd uh take a followup
I'd appreciate it um so I just so I did
the math um and anybody's free to
correct me if I'm wrong because I'm open
to being wrong um looks like the maximum
of number of days
a year that this would be applicable to
is 8 and a half um out of 365 days a
year uh do you think that's an
unreasonable
standard um based on what I read and
using 2080 hours as a normal work year I
think I ran a calculation and it was
more like 12 days perhaps maybe I was
wrong on that I um but uh you know eight
days
um you know it's I I I can't say I mean
depends on the on the business that's
why you know it's hard to uh to dictate
what what's what's the norm uh some
businesses eight days may be fine other
businesses you know a richer number
could be fine it it really depends on on
the circumstances of the business um you
know in our case um you know we like as
I said we uh we were operating on the
three-day six day uh plan for for maybe
15 years and um just through our
experience we we recognize that PTO was
better if you take PTO um you know and
it encompasses everything it gives the
the employee plenty of opportunity in
which case even for a new employee uh
the PTO is is considerably greater than
than the than the eight days because it
vacation all right thank you for your
answer any other questions here in the
committee room seeing none any
[Music]
online see none thank you for your
testimony sir thank you our next call
Rosie Garvey who is supporting and then
next Gary Abbott after her Miss Garvey
are you uh available I see you up there
just you there you go yes hi um I
apologize I keep getting notifications
that my internet is unstable so if I cut
in and out please just let me know um my
name is Rosie Garvey and I'm from
Amherst and I'm a current college senior
with uh two chronic illnesses cystic
fibrosis and rheumatoid arthritis and as
you said I'm speaking in support of
um and I'm 22 years old and so I'm very
in tune with how my body is doing
and but days when I cannot work still
occur much more frequently than I would
like and I no control over that right
now I'm a full-time student but I also
work in retail part-time um I'm lucky
that my managers are very accommodating
and do not require me to come into work
when I am sick but I still have to miss
Garvey
keeps coming in and out or do you want
me to just start
again um is there a way that you
have I I don't know what to tell you um
uh you kept cutting in and out we'll try
it again and and then if we can't um I'm
just going to have to um ask you to send
in written testimony but go ahead again
please oh we I guess we do have your
written testimony but go ahead please
and we'll we'll try this again you can
you you don't have to sorry about that I
did hear that you're a full-time you're
we did hear up to the point where your
time so um I work in retail parttime and
I'm lucky my managers are accommodating
and do not require me to come in when I
am sick but this still means I have to
miss the days worth of pay um I'm also
lucky that I
current with my par of missing a
paycheck however I'm graduating college
in May and when I truly enter the
workforce I'm nervous about what that's
going to mean for me as a chronically
ill
person
in0 M Garvey I don't mean to be rude but
we have a lot of people um that need to
testify you keep breaking up and we
cannot hear you so uh I'm I'm going to
have to accept just your written
testimony I'm sorry we can't hear you um
and I'm going to have to call um Gary
Abbott if you um can
uh Miss Garvey if you can have a better
mechanism a phone call you don't you
have calling in Zoom there is a phone
call there mechanism um then you can
call back and maybe we can get you back
into queue a little a little later um
but thank you I'd like to call on
um um Mr Gary Abbot who opposes this and
after Mr Abott Jennifer friselle uh Mr
Abbot thank you very much chairman
infantine and committee members for the
record my name's Gary Abbot I'm the
Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire uh I'm before you today as I
have been in previous sessions uh
opposed to this legislation I can tell
you that we brought it up before our
board of directors and our legislative
committees and our HR committees and
they all want to retain the company uh
putting together their own vacation and
sick time uh
policies this bill heads us in a
direction of a
prescriptive State policy for all
businesses uh whether full full or
part-time we recognize that we're in
support of sick Le uh but we like to
leave it up to our individual companies
to decide what type of policy and how
much time to be given uh be all part of
those policies uh this seems to put in a
lot of things that uh some companies
have some companies don't some companies
go beyond this so um it also would raise
some issues with smaller firms that
don't do on AC cruel basis this would
mandate in a cruel uh basis of uh
keeping track which smaller firms would
not uh most of the firms that I
represent are larger construction firms
that already have set in place uh very
specific policies regarding sick leave
and therefore I think it's uh from our
position it would be
a uh not a good policy to start writing
these uh individual company policies
into State statutes uh with that we
would hope that the committee would vote
this bill in expedient and I would end
my testimony there thank you very much
opportunity thank you are there any
questions on Zoom from the committee
speaker see none any in the committee
room see none thank you Mr Abbot thank
you very much like to call Jennifer
friselle follow and then after Jennifer
David duvet Jennifer friselle is with
New Hampshire women's Foundation forc
the bill go ahead Jennifer if you're
with
us I am uh good morning thank you
chairman infantine and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Jennifer friselle I work as the Director
of policy at the New Hampshire women's
foundation and we are the only Statewide
nonprofit dedicated to Grant making
research and advocacy on behalf of women
and girls across New Hampshire I'm here
in support of House Bill 590 today uh
two of the areas that are of particular
Focus for the New Hampshire women's
Foundation are women in the workforce
and women as caregivers and those are
two issues that are particularly
highlighted by The Proposal before you
today the women's Foundation has been
monitoring the impact of the coid 19 uh
pandemic uh across the state both
through the funding that we provide to
local nonprofits and also to research um
that we commissioned earlier this year
in partnership with darkmouth um I did
cause to be delivered into your
mailboxes earlier this morning before
the 10:00 a.m. originally scheduled
hearing a copy of a four-page data
report that we just put out at the end
of 2020 that I'm going to be referring
to just a little bit um in some key
points of my
testimony um the larger summary of being
that women are carrying a
disproportionate number of the health
and economic burdens in our state as we
move through coid and women need the
legislature to be prioritizing public
policies that are going to help them be
an equal part of the recovery so some of
the key findings of the report that we
looked at over nine months of women's
experience with coid um concluded that
women are experiencing a higher
percentage of coid cases and coid
deaths that female workers face
increased occupational hazards because
of their over representation in the jobs
that are viewed are essential uh
Workforce or our Frontline occupations
in New Hampshire that 68% of that
Workforce is
women that more women are losing
employment and earnings as a result of
the pandemic than men and I document the
unemployment trends that have shown this
as well as um the typical the different
types of economic sectors where women do
and don't have the flexibility to work
at home and how that impacts their
economic opportunities and their need
for sick leave um and then finally um
across the state and across the country
um most of the responsibility for
caregiving whether it's as a result of
disrupted child care or disrupted um
School access and remote school and
hybrid school is falling on women and so
this is a very important bill um to make
certain that women have the opportunity
to have uh the time that they need and
the economic support that they need the
very same industries that where women
are over represented in New Hampshire
that has them spending more time on the
Frontline of this pandemic are many of
the lower wage industries that are less
likely to uh provide benefits like sick
Leaf similarly as you've heard from
previous uh Witnesses today um women are
more likely to carry multiple part-time
jobs than their male counterparts and as
a result they're likely to have less
access to sick leave the need for paid
sick daes is more urgent than ever and
we know that if we continue to force
women who are in some of the most
vulnerable economic situ situations um
to choose between their financial
well-being and the health of their
family and Community they will have no
choice but to choose their own economic
survival um there have been several
economists um including a few here at
the state who have said that the best
economic stimulus for us to move our way
out of this pandemic and um in Inspire
and um generate the state economy is to
make sure um that women have the same
access to return to full employment and
to retain the flexibility and employment
that they have for their fam's health
and well-being and therefore um we
strongly not only believe that this is
an important policy for women and men
and for the health of our families and
communities but it's also a critical
policy inclosing the gender disparity
that now exists in the state with regard
to who has sick leave and who does not
so with that I'll thank you for the
opportunity to testify and certainly
answer any questions or be available for
any
followup thank you are there any
questions here in the committee room for
a
speaker seeing n any questions for the
Zoom I do not see any
hands uh thank you Mr Brazil for for
your um
testimony thank you I'd like to uh Now
call David juv from the business and
industry Association who opposes the
bill and then I'll followed by Joel I I
wasowski Mr ju thank you Mr chair
members of the committee I trust you can
hear me okay yes thank you uh for the
record my name is Dave juv I'm a senior
vice president for public policy at the
business and industry Association we are
here uh this morning in opposition to
House Bill 590 our objection to the bill
is twofold one is philosophical and one
one is practical the philosophical one
has already been touched on by other
speakers who are opposed to the
legislation recognizing that it doesn't
really make sense to for the state to
require a one-size fits-all employee
benefit I assure you that businesses
large and small understand the
importance of a paid sick leave benefit
and the businesses that are not
providing it are not doing so because
they don't recognize the importance of
it they're doing so because they don't
have the fin fincial resources to offer
such a benefit every company in New
Hampshire right now is in competition
for employees and every employer
understands uh what they need to do and
what they need to provide in terms of
employee benefits to both attract and
retrain um retain employees so I would
ask that the committee um find this PO
an expedient the other area I mentioned
is a practical one and it relates
directly to the Co 19 pandemic right now
there are many businesses probably many
of the ones who uh are not able to
provide a uh paid sick leave benefit
that're in a life and death struggle to
survive and passing this type of
legislation which would create uh
extraordinary costs on the part of some
businesses uh may be the Tipping Point
that would put them out of business and
I don't think that would be in either
the best interest of the state or the
employees that are currently working so
i' would ask you to oppose this Bill
thank you Mr chair I'd be happy to
answer any
questions any questions for the speaker
here in the committee
room seeing none on uh committee members
on Zoom I will recognize representative
Michael
kahill thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh Mr juv for taking my question um I
understand that businesses are having a
very difficult time but the the it's the
employees of the these businesses that
are also having a very difficult time
and if they don't earn much money to
begin with they're working
part-time and then they get sick and
they they can't come to work and then
they can't pay this bill or that bill or
fix their car so again they can't go to
work um what is the what would
the how can we motivate if we can't reg
legislate how can we motivate these
businesses who you say are are not
choosing because they don't like the
concept that but that they can't afford
it it maybe if you can't afford to
provide for your employees then you
really can't afford a
business well uh I would suggest that
this bill represents uh somewhat of a a
downward death spiral and I would
suggest that although a uh person
working a lower wage job and without a
paid sick leave benefit is not ideal for
for that individual being unemployed
because the business goes out of
business is even less
ideal thank you I do I appreciate that
you representative agitant has a
question you recognized speak thank you
Mr chairman um I wanted to follow up on
um comment you made about uh businesses
going out of business and this might be
the Tipping Point that sends certain
business businesses out um I will be
generous and use the uh math that a
prior speaker used um in order to um you
know have a more conservative estimate
um when I did the math timing eight days
of available paid sick leave the year uh
times eight hours a day uh times $10 an
hour which is about the um what I'm
assuming is a lower wage that still puts
that person competitive but puts them
out of range for uh you know the
benefits that you'd get at a larger
business we're talking about
$640 a year uh per each employee at one
of these small businesses that uh would
theoretically be crippled by this
devastating legislation um does that
really Square um do you think
$640 or even $700 per employee would
really destroy uh some of these
businesses that otherwise would struggle
to um comply with this
legislation uh thank you representative
I guess I would respectfully suggest it
doesn't matter what I think I assure you
that small business people are equally
good at math and that they provide the
benefit packages that they uh are able
to provide to attract and retain
employees um so I um don't really know
how many would be driven out of business
by this but I can tell you that the
struggle right now is real and that
there are a lot of businesses smaller
businesses especially businesses in the
uh travel and tourism uh related sector
of our economies restaurants uh small
hotels that are really hurting right now
burden thank you any other questions
point I can't see it there I can see it
up there represent representative
avalani has a question I don't see it on
my
screen he's
there I see I see his screen I don't see
a yellow hands up but representative
aini if you recognized to um a question
if you have
one it's actually a comment Mr chairman
if I may y
um I I'd like some clarification on
representative kill's comment that if
people can't afford SI time that they
can't afford a business I'm I just want
correctly I did I
[Music]
reply that is how I understood
it any other questions thank you Mr I
have a question for Mr duv if I could as
well go ahead you
recognize thank you and thank you Mr du
for taking the question um could you
respond upon the hospitality industry
and the devast and the issues that we're
facing at this particular time with um
employees um having to
close um due to potential issues um the
lack of distancing between tables and
those ideas there that allow us to
operate at a severely reduced capacity
um and that this would be a burden at
this time to imply on every small
business in the state yes I think the
pressure is coming from two different
areas one is external and the reality is
because of Co 19 and um uh guidelines
that are in place not just in New
Hampshire but around the country people
are making decisions to travel less than
they normally would and that's probably
a good thing in fact it's I'm certain
it's a good thing is is a method for
reducing the uh spread of uh Corona
virus so right away restaurants and and
other Hospitality oriented businesses
are um seeing less demand for what they
can provide on top of that are uh issues
that you raised uh New Hampshire
specific guidelines in terms of uh
number of customers that are able to be
let in the dividers that need to be put
up the uh social distancing that needs
to be in place all of these have
um
caused our customers and revenue at
restaurants to go down and that probably
won't change until you know a sufficient
number of us have been vaccinated and we
see a a a pretty significant downturn in
the uh incidents of of people uh uh
disease all right thank you any further
questions
Josh representative
kale thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr J uh while I appreciate that the
times are especially difficult for the
restaurants and hotels and and many
Industries um would you agree that this
bill if if it were to pass would not
take effect until until the summer at
the earliest and that certainly they
would be some opportunity to be phased
in or perhaps adjust this uh I I don't
know that we can legislate for
conditions that that are here now and
will Pro will most likely not continue
uh
indefinitely I represent kill uh thank
you I don't have the same confidence
that you do that things are going to be
dramatically improved by the summertime
I think there will be a gradual
Improvement is uh the New Hampshire
population and the population around the
country uh gets vaccinated but I think
everyone agrees that is going to take
some time to happen and but aside from
that it doesn't really address bia's
concern which is we don't think it's the
appropriate role for the state to
mandate one size fits-all employee
benefits every company is different some
companies have the ability to offer very
generous benefits other companies are
such that they don't have the ability to
offer uh the same
level thank
you thank you before I call our next
speaker I just wanted to make an
announcement we will be
um continuing through the lunch hour uh
to try to get caught up for uh this
morning so uh legislators in the room if
you'd like to go and eat or whatever you
feel free to do so all you guys at home
don't make us too jealous but you're
feel free to to eat if you are eating
please possibly put yourself on the
camera off so there you go
representative Sullivan uh originally I
had planned to have a phone call Caucus
with the Republican members of the
committee at noon uh for those that
could have attended uh via phone and
those in person we're going we're not
going to do that today I'll have to
reschedule that to some other
time so with that I will continue on
unless there's any questions other the
committee
members I'll continue
on
uh Joel owitz uh representing himself in
support and then after Joel uh Ray Ellen
duville uh Mr W Wast are you with us and
I hope I did not destroy your name I do
not see him
online I'm sorry Christine I don't see
him online in the queue he does come
will and um just just in case did um
Rosie Garvey ever try to come back
on no I didn't see her come back on okay
uh rayel and duville followed by Amy
Bradley
rayen there you
go thank you thank you Mr chairman can
you hear me yes ma'am okay thank you I
have a daughter with a chronic health
condition when she was diagnosed with
type 1 diabetes at the age of two she
spent uh time in a hospital and we had
uh subsequently had multiple Medical in
incidents that required constant
attention uh we alternated staying with
her in the hospital for one of us it was
tough to manage with the employer in
addition a child with a seral serious
medical illness creates economic stress
putting parents in advice between caring
for their child and their employment
it's more difficult when one does not
have pay time off from work to make all
necessary appointments for their child
um so many families in New Hampshire are
in this situation right now we we made
it work and our employers did what they
could but it shouldn't come down to
having a good employer for parents to
ensure the child will get necessary care
and still pay their bills the pandemic
has made this even harder for working
families and I urge you to pass this
you thank you very much for your
testimony looking for any
questions for the
room anything on online on Zoom any
committee members any questions I see
none thank you very
much like to call on Amy Bradley
followed by
MK kilcoin Amy Bradley representing
herself is in
support Miss
Bradley or Brady I'm
sorry sorry I have Tom Brady on the mind
Miss Brady good morning can you hear me
yes ma'am oh can you guys see me at all
or is it just audio just your picture
just my picture well hopefully it's a
good one uh well good morning actually
it's good afternoon um ladies and
gentlemen of committee thank you uh
representatives for your time I'm here
uh to give testimony in support of House
Bill 590 again my name is Amy Brady and
I live in Hollis New
Hampshire first and foremost I'm a
mother of two uh a career uh employee
and spouse of a combat veteran uh both
most my children have life-threatening
chronic medical conditions one my
99-year-old daughter uh was diagnosed
with type 1 diabetes um and she is
currently
nine I've had to use paid sick leave
through my employer but that's not
always the case and sometimes I have to
take leave without pay I have often had
to miss workk to ensure that she gets to
her numerous monthly doctor's
appointments working people should have
access to paid sick time no family
should have to choose between a paycheck
or taking care of a child with a chronic
illness but too often this impacts every
everything for a parent with a child
with a chronic illness in terms of
long-term Economic Security not just
paying bills but retirement use of
Public Assistance programs unemployment
costs and health care
benefits for caregivers without access
to paid sick time it is categorically
difficult to make ends meet even for
caregivers who do have sick time such as
myself we end up using most of it to
take care of our sick loved ones and
we're often left without time to take
care of
ourselves and as someone who identifies
with a person with a disability it's a
real
problem the driving concept of economic
legislation is to correct failures of
the market
economy paid sick leave as it stands
today is a failure we encourage citizens
to work and contribute to the economy
but people need families to be healthy
and happy which is their own right a
current system forces a choice between
these Alternatives and far too many of
us of our most critical
workers and as Co has shown incentivize
employees to go to work so they can keep
paying for their
rent this conflict must be removed from
the
system if we want safe and productive
workers who are able to make choices
consistent with public health
additionally this issue
disproportionately affects women such as
myself that are often the primary
caregivers within the family as a
primary caregiver I've had to step away
from promotions because of the need to
make all of the appointments for my
children and the negative attitudes that
employers have when you're taking paid
or unpaid leave or
entitlements we need better systems in
place to ensure that women can remain in
the workplace especially during a
pandemic and economic
crisis else Bill 590 would help of note
hearing some of today's testimonies from
the companies opposing it appears they
also reflect from male dominated labor
markets and I would ask them what is
your ratio of male to female employees
thank you for your time today uh Amy
Brady from Hollis New Hampshire thank
you thank you Amy and thank you to your
family for the service to this country
have any questions of anyone in the
committee
online C thank you very much Miss Brady
thank
youon I would like to call on
MK Hill Coin followed by Sheila orench
us I don't know MK it say Mike Mike
kilcoin anyone um you see anyone U I do
not see MK kilcoin M kilcoin I believe
is uh supporting him is in support of
the
bill will next call on Shi or Ranch
followed by Mark McMurphy
us yes she is yes I am thank you we can
hear you
fine good I can't hear myself I have
been fascinating with fascinated with
this process while I was waiting for
things to come back I was again reading
through the
bill a few points Point came up
outstandingly to me under the acral of
paid sick time it
says employees shall not acrw or use
more than 72 hours of paid sick time in
a calendar year unless the employer
selects a higher
limit with that limit I don't understand
where the 8 days or all the other math
comes from but I don't want to get an
answer yet the people who have lived
with this bill can answer that later I
have a
few key points first of all this bill is
a good starting point it's part of the
entire
Matrix of creating a family-friendly
economy so that New Hampshire can
attract and retain young people Working
Families this is a little piece of
that but it's a start having three days
of sick time is just a start from my
point of view as a small business
owner I don't think it's
unreasonable given enough time to work
this into your business plan my husband
and I are what some people might call
Elders we're 73 and we're operating
multiple
businesses but for all those years
before we jumped ship on the corporate
life
we were employees I've had the
experience of having a teenager have a
mental health crisis and losing my job
because I needed to go to
appointments and family counseling
appointments and it had to be both of us
because we only had one
car when I could not answer my boss as
to how long is this going to go on with
a specific amount of time he said then
you have to I have to get someone else
into your job there was no safety net
for
that I've also had the experience of my
granddaughter who at the time was about
three a skinny little whippy child who
almost
died because an employee went to work at
that Wendy's in
Framingham
Massachusetts with Sal manella which was
misdiagnosed Miss diagnosed misdiagnosed
as flu because the symptoms are quite
different but that employee went to work
sick and infected many many other people
also but she was Tiny and she could have
died I totally
agree
with is it
vanchu that paid time off is better
if you have the resources you shouldn't
have to lie and say you're sick because
you want to do something else because
you have to take someone else or take
else so paid time off is better but most
small companies can't afford this
looking at the language of the
bill this is not requiring any company
that has a superior plan to change
it but it is being a little bit
prescriptive about how sick time can be
to the description of
it I was concerned that health
professionals did not
include Mental Health Counselors or
Rehabilitation
counselors they're not
doctors they may be
referred to from the doctors but you
don't have to be a licensed Medical
Professional to provide Mental Health
Services if anything I would like to see
this bill
strengthened to
include a little bit more in the
definition of what a medical
professional is I'd
also love
to have the idea of basic sick
time that's not going to be enough but
it's better than nothing the
relationship between an employer and an
employee should be based on trust
honesty
compassion if you have to lie to
somebody about why you're not at work
work or if you can't take a day off to
take care of yourself or someone
else then it's hard to have that kind of
trust I would love to have questions
from
anyone I have my timer
set thank
members thank you thank you for your
testimony have any questions of the
members
online no any question of the members
here in the
committee um since you ask since you'd
like a question I have one for you on
page two of the bill that you referred
to employees shall not acue or use more
than 72 hours of page six time account
on page 2 on line
um that is just for sick time
bill greatly exceed that for other
mechanisms for other reasons I don't see
anywhere I would love to have someone
who is more familiar with the bill tell
me where the numbers came from of more
than three days that was my major
enough my numbers were lower than that
so
so if you can't acrw more than 72 hours
in a year that's pretty explicit 275 I
two acrel of paid sick time number
three I don't understand the I do
understand the objection of the business
Community to anyone telling them what to
do most of the companies in Bia which I
used to belong to and participate in are
much larger than my companies
this bill is not trying to address the
companies's doing a good job this bill
is trying to create some kind of a
minimum safety net so that the people
who are most
disadvantaged have something at least
something if you have the flu you should
not be going to work for five days three
sick days isn't going to cover it but
it's better than nothing and it's a good
start I'm really proud of the people who
sponsored and crafted this Bill thank
questions thank you for your
testimony now I'd like to call on Mark
McMurphy followed by uh Dr Randy
Hayes is Mark McMurphy with us I here Mr
chairman thank you right
we I support this bill and agree uh very
much with uh representative wahner's
assessment and reasoning uh behind the
bill um so I want to add just a few
points that haven't been brought up yet
number one the the
mechanics of whatever they may end up
being of how
to uh account for this is pretty
standard stuff that uh if you use a
payroll company or payroll software most
of that uh most of the companies in the
software can account for the
accumulation of paid sick
time um by the way I'm the executive
director of white birch uh Center in
hener we do child care school age
programming and Senior
programming
um there is definitely a cost to
turnover of employees if an employee
leaves um even if an employee is fired
um my standard here when we lose an
employee is 18 months before that
employee feels completely comfortable
with their job the workplace the culture
and it's an expensive proposition to uh
replace somebody and if somebody leaves
because they don't have paid sick time
um that cost far outweighs the 72 hours
of sick time that they've acred in my
opinion and finally we deal with a lot
of clients who have to work they can't
work from home and they drop their
children off for child care and the
number of times that we've had Parents
approach us over the last seven years
since I've been here to ask for us to
provide free child care because they've
lost their job for whatever reason and
some people have lost their job because
they've had to attend to a sick child
it's uh it's a it's a memorable number
it's not every day but uh it's
definitely something that concerns me
and also when they do lose their job and
they have to go look for a job they need
child care so for the employers who um
are unable to provide sick leave and
when somebody does have to work without
pay or they're fired um the committee
should understand that there's a cost to
that to other businesses either
utilities landlords or in our case uh
child care where we want to help that
family um as a nonprofit but uh we are
absorbing a cost with that and that's uh
speaker seeing none online any in the
committee
room seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony Mr chairman yes I'm sorry
would it be out of order to provide a
point of clarification
on one of the prior questions and
testimony um I don't think so what did
you I don't understand what you're
trying to do I just I the previous
speaker to this one um there was some
confusion around the math and hours and
I just figured that out and wanted to
take an opportunity to clarify in case
anybody was confused I I will give you
that Latitude go ahead representative
thank you Mr chairman um so looking back
at uh page two where we were talking
about employees shall not acre or use
more than 72 hours of paid sick time uh
in a calendar year unless the employer
sets a littleit higher so what I did was
um started at the 280 Hour Week standard
divided that by 30 it comes out to uh 69
rounding up to 70 um so I think that's
just the base standard to make the math
work with the uh one hour of paid sick
time for every 32 hours with a little
bit a wiggle room uh just in case uh an
employees clocked in for a little bit
longer uh or something like that so that
does add up in that regard yes I have
you oh trying to utilize um the 72 hours
pay tick time that's allowed under this
bill and um one hour ACR for every 30
hours of of work which Loosely on it 20
2 80
hour year comes out to about
29 you know 70 7 69 70 out it it's too
short of
72 we just trying to clarify the numbers
since we were kind of throwing around
some numbers so y appreciate that a lot
going on here um like to call on uh
retired Dr Randy Hayes followed by Molly
Lun Owen
Dr Hayes is a New Hampshire Medical
Society and is in support of the bill Dr
are you with us yes thank you Mr
chairman can you hear me yes we can
great um I appreciate the opportunity to
speak uh to those online and the to the
committee
specifically uh my name is Randy Hayes
I'm a retired family doctor practiced in
conquered for 35 years and during my
years of medical practice practice I met
hundreds of people who were unable to
take proper care of their own and their
fam's needs due to a lack of paid sick
time I think representative walner spoke
about uh the 33 some OD percent of the
total Workforce in New Hampshire that
currently does not have a single sick
day that's paid available to them and I
would submit that if you took that
percentage and focused primarily on
people known to be at high risk for such
a lack of an essential benefit those
being people of low income part-time
workers people of color the
uninsured um and new Americans not to
mention the predominant women uh who um
uh staff the workforce of Essential
Medical uh providers in settings like
home care and nursing home care you
would get a much larger percentage of
that portion of the workforce being
deprived of a single day of paid sick
time uh I go into a little more detail
in my written testimony but let me just
say that uh when these high-risk persons
have to lose a day's pay in order to
address an acute personal or family
illness many Granite Staters now have to
choose one of the following three
harmful and lousy options one is to go
to work sick and many uh speakers have
already alluded to the risk of such
Behavior not only to the employee but to
the fellow employees and even to the
employer as well as to the public
especially during pandemic time the
second poor option is to delay necessary
care until the problem becomes so urgent
that one has to resort to emergency room
care for a worsening and more difficult
to treat Progressive illness this is a
very expensive proposition in terms of
the finances of Health Care and also a
very inferior choice of where to get the
best care at the most opportune moment
and the third uh very uh un uh un
optional uh I'm sorry unoptimal choice
is to delegate the care of a sick child
or a disabled senior family member to a
kind but ill-informed neighbor who can
transport the patient to a health care
professional for care this is an
inferior choice because the neighbor
cannot detail the essential information
and provide the advocacy for such a sick
family member um uh at a very important
time uh we in medicine realize today
that the family doctors have receded
from the front lines of serious health
care and um this is for obvious complex
reasons but leads many people to have to
deal with strangers when dealing with
hospital or medical emergencies without
the input of their family doctor and uh
all the more reason to allow family
advocates who are employed in the
workforce to be able to take time at
relatively short notice to do absolutely
crucial advocacy for their family
members so in conclusion I would say
that paid ACR sick time reduces the
financial and emotional pressures of to
employees and employers during a time of
urgent
illness I believe uh the assistance
offered by this bill uh would not be
inherently abused and contrary to some
testimony would not be financially
abusive though it be prescriptive uh to
the smaller employers we've talked about
today I believe HB 590 will contribute
to a healthier Workforce and a more
familyfriendly economy thank you and I'm
very open to taking any
questions thank you your testimony any
online seeing none any questions or
members in the committee
room seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you I'd like to call on
Molly lond
us thank you so much Mr chairman can you
hear me all right yes we can excellent
thank you um for the record my name is
Molly Lun Owen I live in Manchester New
Hampshire and thank you so much to the
committee members and the public for
being here and your grace with a tricky
technology situation I really
appreciated that um I am writing in
support of HB 590 I'm a new mom to a
really chubby and Happ 9-month-old who
thankfully is sleeping in the room next
door so you shouldn't hear too much
noise from her during this testimony um
my husband is an engineer and a navy
reservist and he's preparing to deploy
to the Middle East for 10 months
starting this
spring so with all due respect to the
business owners who spoke um before me a
general PTO might work for a large
company a construction company or a
manufacturing company but I've worked in
nonprofits my whole life and the reality
is
that the one I most recently worked for
could not afford to maintain a
short-term disability policy and so we
had two weeks of of sick time and
disability that or excuse me sick time
and paid leave we could use our
discretion throughout the year um I was
almost hospitalized with the flu last
spring and I missed almost two weeks of
work was pre-co and I was pregnant and
in my previous job had I been working
there I that would have been the
entirety of my paid leave so I would
have returned from from sick leave to
have no maternity leave and also no
leave for doctor's appointments for
myself or for my new baby and also no
time to be with my husband before or
after his deployment and thankfully I
run my current organization so we do
offer paid sick
leave but most military spouses in New
Hampshire and at least a third of
families who are single parent families
don't have a second parent available um
in fact their their you know their
partner is basically on deployment
permanently because it's just them and
it's it's really not fair for working
moms specifically working parents in
general to have to choose their families
and their work because I want to work I
want to contribute to the economy in New
Hampshire I don't want to drop out of
the workforce because the work I do is
important to me and I urge you to the
views of those who spoke before me and
testimony in supporting HB
590 thank you for your testimony again
thank you to your family for services
country any questions here in the
committee
online I don't see any thank you very
much for your testimony thank you
Christina I'm just looking to see if
Rosie Garvey or Joel
owitz or MK
cube I do not see but give me just a
moment to
look Rosie Garvey who having connection
problems Joel waskowitz who did was not
here and MK Hill Coin who was not
here I do not see them though um oh I do
see a Paar perhaps she's using a
different let's see if that is
her
here I'm sorry we were trying to connect
uh via phone I can put this is Paula
Garvey here Rosie garvey's Mom I would
like to put Rosie on first because she
has firsthand information that I think
might be very useful for this bill that
is fine thank you we will recognize
Rosie Garvey who was calling in with
Paula Garvey and after Rosie we will
hear from Paula Garvey go
ahead
hello go ahead uh Miss Garvey you're on
the
air
no Rosie yes hello sorry um yeah we got
some complicated I was on my phone it's
okay so um um my name is Rosie Garvey
and I'm from Amherst and um as I said
before I have two chronic illnesses I
assist six fiis and I have rheumatoid
arthritis and that's why I am in support
of today's sick Le bill um right now I'm
a full-time college student but I also
work in retail part-time and while I
have really accommodating managers that
still means whenever I'm sick I miss a
whole day worth of pay um I'm lucky
currently to live with my parents so
that minimizes the stress of having to
miss a paycheck but I'm going to be
graduating college in May and when that
does happen and I have to enter the
workforce truly I'm nervous about being
a chronically ill person in the
workforce um in 2020 alone I had to be
hospitalized three times all for over
three days and had countless sick days
from work in school and that was a
considerably healthy year for me when
symptoms of my illnesses pop up at
random and without warning I wake up and
I don't get to choose whether or not to
go to work I'm often in too much pain to
get out of bed or have to immediately
call my doctor and get to the
hospital if paid sick lead were required
by the state on days where I'm so unwell
that I cannot work I would be able to
focus on getting better and not on
missing a paycheck it's not whether or
not I'm like willing to go to work sick
I'm physically unable to go to work sick
so I either lose the paycheck or I get
paid um my medical conditions cost me
enough in term of hot in terms of
hospital bills prescriptions and other
unexpected costs so the possibility of
not getting paid for days I am sick just
adds to that Financial
strain um I also know that I'm just one
story of a New Hampshire citizen who
would be very positively impacted by
this bill I hope you'll consider those
of us who want the opportunity to be
successful in the workforce and don't
deserve to be punished financially for
the unfair hand we've been dealt and I
hope you'll consider that while making
your decision thank you so much
thank you um so my mom also signed up to
speak she just let me jump on would it
be okay if she spoke as well um yes but
would you please hold online because
we're going to ask if there's any
questions about your testimony perfect
thank you any questions online for the
speaker not any in the hearing
room thank you very much for sticking on
and going through and we will
Paula
G good morning good afternoon um thank
you for allowing me to hop on to this
call I will be very brief H I think
Rosie's story um probably probably gives
a a better feel for this bill than than
me so my name is Paula Garvey I live in
Amherst New Hampshire and I support this
bill to ensure access to paage sick Le
in New Hampshire as you know my daughter
Rosie was born with cystic fibrosis and
this is chronic health condition that
affects the lungs and many other organs
CF requires a lot of Medical Care
frequent do doctors visits and
unfortunately
hospitalizations um at the age of 15
Rosie was also diagnosed with rheumatoid
arthritis which had a huge impact on her
health both conditions have led to
multiple hospitalizations and
surgeries and honestly it has been very
challenging as a family to work and to
care for a child with health
conditions um in the past when Rosie was
hospitalized I was fortunate to have 4
days paid leave but after that I would
have to use unpaid leave this was
particularly stressful um for me my
husband and I used to juggle our sick
days to ensure one parent was available
on one occasion my older daughter uh who
lives in New York came home to support
us when Ros was hospitalized because we
used our sick days I cannot uh for a
moment
understand or be able to put myself in a
position where I had no paid sickly days
uh parents with children of chronic
health conditions have to attend
multiple appointments when Rosie is
healthy she is Clinic every three months
um often with appointments between
clinic visits also Rosie is 22 now so
she is independent but H in the past and
I know there are many other families who
really struggle to juggle uh working and
having a child with a chronic health
condition is very very difficult to
manage work and sick days at time and
then lastly can I just add that on a
general note um and as pandemic has
thought it it is imperative to stay at
home and feeling unw so as not to spread
infection I used to work in the school
system and was exposed to to many
viruses germs but H and I know how I
know the impact it can have and we all
know at this stage um knowing that
people have a cushion of some pay I
think would make it easier for us to
make the the right decision uh thank you
for for allowing me to to hop in like
this and if you have any questions I
answer okay any questions for the
speaker I see none in the committee
room see
online I do not thank you uh Miss Garvey
uh Miss Garvey uh for your
testimony I have one last speaker Susan
speaker I'm sorry I didn't catch
that
Susan
lmer Christina do we have anyone else in
the queue waiting to speak
um we do have a few people that signed
up after um you were delivered your
sheet and many of them have their hands
raised so it looks like we have about
five folks who are looking to speak in
addition okay please since
okay Kristen uh you are you are
recognized to speak
thank you it just took me a minute to
unmute um so I am a professor at
Dartmouth uh College um but I used to be
at the Cary school um at UNH and when I
was there I uh conducted analysis and
and uh fielded a study on the gr State
poll and asked some questions this was
in
2018 about um I asked questions of
workers in New Hampshire whether or not
they had paid sck days from their
employer and so I provided uh written
testimony last night um but I was
teaching so I didn't know today I taught
so I didn't know if I would make it in
uh in time to provide any written uh any
um oral testimony so I just want to draw
your attention to the
um the testimony that I provided in a
written form um and basically I analyzed
the granite state poll data from 2018
and looked at um the percent of uh New
Hampshire workers who lack access to
paid six sick days so in
2018 uh 32% of New Hampshire New
Hampshire workers lacked access and I um
analyze the data looking at where some
discrepancies lied in terms of those who
have access and those who don't and you
can see that in table one in my uh
written testimony and so um workers who
work part-time are much more likely to
lack access than those who work
full-time um this you know isn't
surprising because uh a lot of our um a
lot of our workplace standards are
guaranteed for um you know it's it's
tied to full-time employment but we do
have workplace standards that are
guaranteed for all workers regardless of
their work hours such as the minimum
wage and safety codes um the other uh
group that often um doesn't have paid
sick days are those that are lowincome
workers um so 46% of those in the
workforce that are earning $600 per week
or less lack paid sick days and that
compares to only 18% that lack access um
among those who are earning more than
1,600 um per week so we see this large
discrepancy
um in access to paid sick time based on
your earnings um women who have um been
called upon during this pandemic to
provide so much of the caregiving
um 30 um 32% I think it was yeah no 30
34% lack access to um to PID sick days
through their employer um and this
potentially compromises the health and
economic well-being of families so in
September I'll just draw your attention
to um the mass amount of women who left
the labor force in September of 20 2020
that was
865,000
workers across the United States um were
women who were leaving the labor force
and some of that um one could argue has
to do with the lack of work supports
such as paid sick days or Paid Family
Leave um or other as aspects as well
um and then finally workers who um are
employed in firms with fewer than 50
employees um also lack access to paid
stick time compared to those that work
in larger firms um 52% of those that are
in those smaller firms and as you all
know small firms are the engine of the
New Hampshire economy in 2015 40% of
workers uh were employed in these
smaller firms um so I just wanted to
draw your attention to some of the data
um you know I know that employers um you
know are providing paid sick time but um
we still have this
uneven um access in our state um
depending on you know where you work how
much you earn um and this uh this bill
could help address some of those
inequalities happy to take any
questions thank you Miss Smith any
questions here in the committee
online say none thank you very much for
your testimony Christina who is our next
speaker I see attorney
Mory I'm sorry I did not hear you who
attorney Mor y oh
okay hi hello um in fact I am a doctor
and my first name is Addie I'm so sorry
no it's okay common mistake so and I'm
actually talking to you from um
Dartmouth Hitchcock I'm in our
pediatric
ICU and um because of that and because
I'm also a mom and a human being in this
time in our life I'm very familiar with
the need for paid sick leave um and I
just want to eluate that we just went
through this large pandemic which we're
still struggling with that um sometimes
can be called the great equalizer but I
think also what we're faced with is that
it is um has been a great revealer of a
lot of our healthc care
disparities and um and it's an
opportunity for us to work towards
rectifying some of those and paid sick
leave is one way to do that
I think um and I think moving forward
and also representing the New Hampshire
Medical Society today it's important for
everybody to know that the data driven
approach to this is that actually it
doesn't cost businesses more and it
doesn't put businesses out of um out of
business it tends to actually save them
money in the long run and um and it's
been an argument against paid sickly for
a long long time both at the national
and state level but the numbers actually
as others have um attested to work in
favor of businesses and small businesses
alike this is this is a big opportunity
um to put New Hampshire in line with
several other states that have pic leave
Bill thank you Dr Mori Ari any questions
uh in the committee
Doctor
head Jan hello can you hear
me m craige head uh you are recognized
to
speak hi can you hear me all
right Christine
yes
Christie we can't hear you very well are
you able to turn up the volume or get
device we are unable to hear her in the
committee
room okay it sounds like she's gonna
call in um we can go come back to her
please go we have Amanda Sears
next Amanda Sears from the campaign for
family I can't read it all Amanda you
are recognized to speak thank you uh can
you hear me yes ma'am great um thank you
chairman infantine and members of the
committee uh uh my name is Amanda Sears
I'm the director of the campaign for a
familyfriendly economy um excuse me we
are a New Hampshire based uh group
working to advance policies that help
people to make ends meet and to be there
for their families when they need to be
and we're here in support of uh this
bill uh this bill would ensure people
who work can rely on their income to pay
their bills um that they can continue to
make ends meet when they need to be out
of work for a day or a few days because
they or a family member are sick you've
heard about some of the um lack of
access that uh about a third of our
state faces with paid sick time um so I
won't get into too much of that um but I
think it's really important to focus on
the fact that not all working people
have equal access and so there is this
real disparity between who has and does
not have access to paid sick days um
people who you heard from Dr Smith that
people who work part-time hours are far
less likely to have access other people
who are far less likely are people who
have caregiving responsibilities for
other people so that includes both
parents especially mothers um and
families who have a person um within
their family experiencing a disability
and one of the main reasons for that is
because those families are often working
at patching together part-time jobs that
they can patch together around their
caregiving
responsibilities um that means that the
status quo in which all people don't
have the opportunity to earn paid sick
time leads to the people who are most
likely to need it because they have
caregiving responsibilities are least
likely to have it at the same time uh
only about half of people working for
less than $14 an hour have any paid time
off they can use for a sick day um
people working for the lowest wages are
the most likely to be unable to pay for
their basic needs when they lose pay
from a sick day that they um don't get
to take as earned paid time off for the
typical family who doesn't have access
to paid sick days three days of lost pay
due to illness is equal to more than the
family's grocery budget for the month so
this has a really big impact not having
access to to paid sick days has a big
impact on the ability for for low-income
families in particular to be able to
meet their basic needs
needs and working people without access
to paid sick days are nearly twice as
likely to report to work with contagious
illnesses and this puts um not only
themselves at risk but also their
co-workers and their customers it also
as you've heard from some um schools and
and child care providers um ends up
making it so that a lot more children
are showing up to school and to child
care without access with um when they
are sick or family member is sick um
paid sick day laws that are in effect in
many stes States across the country and
in um other states across New England
have all been shown to drive down rates
of contagious illnesses because people
are able to stay home when they're sick
and the pandemic has made it crystal
clear that we're all better off when
people who are sick can stay home uh
without access people are going to work
sick and I wanted to address a couple of
things that came up from other speakers
um one was the um notion that um some
employers offer paid time off a pool
that can be used um and so they um don't
offer specifically paid sick time this
bill accounts for that and and enables
that as long as that paid time off can
be used to satisfy the requirements of
this chapter that it can be used for
paid sick time to care for oneself or a
family member that paid time off pool
can be used in lie of this so that
employer would not need to offer any
additional paid sick time as long as
they have a a policy that covers paid
sick time as as indicated in this this
law this bill um there was also a a um
statement that was made um by um banek
about um you know saying that you don't
tell us what to pay people um you know
you shouldn't tell us that people should
have these benefits but in fact we do
tell um employers that they need to have
they have to pay a minimum wage so we do
set a minimum wage for indicating what
um employers need to pay people that's
what this bill does is it sets a minimum
floor saying you have to offer some paid
sick time to people it sets a minimum
and it allows employers to give anything
above that and to implement it through a
paid sick time or a paid time off policy
but it sets a floor for this benefit
just like the minimum wage sets a floor
for wages um and then there um you know
were concerns about the fears of
business impact um and what I would just
say you know as as Dr Mory already said
if you actually look at the data for
states that have implemented and cities
um and communities that have implemented
um this kind of a policy that doesn't
bear out
um and so in fact um they those places
that have implemented paid sick time
floors um that set a minimum require
requirement have not seen a negative
impact in the business Community because
of those policies and um all of our
neighboring states at this point do have
um policies Maine it's a paid time off
policy the other states are paid sick
day policies but do have these kinds of
policies in place so we are an outlier
among among our neighbor States and with
that I'd close and just say you know
everybody gets sick and so every body
deserves the opportunity to take time
off from work um and uh we it's in our
best interest to have people um able to
stay stay home when they are sick so
thank you very much for your
time thank you any questions for Miss
Sears in the committee
room sing n any
online singan thank you very much um we
are getting short on time I have to open
another hearing at 1:00 which we
postponed is Christina CRA head on or
Christie I do see another phone number
um Miss Craighead if you are there can
you raise your hand U by using the star
six
button oh okay we'll see if that's
her all right you're Avail we're ready
to speak Miss crae
unfortunately we still can't hear you
miss Craig uh do we have any other uh we
have one more person in the
Weinberg Mr Weinberg uh you um
recognized can you hear me yes we can
awesome well good afternoon thank you
for having this opportunity uh my name
is Jonathan Weinberg I 21 years old and
I'm a recently elected member of the
conquered school board however I am here
in my capacity as an individual and not
speaking on behalf of the board we all
know New Hampshire has to do everything
possible to attract and retain young
Working Families we have a rapidly aging
population so much so that we have a
Statewide committee dedicated to
addressing the startling Revelation
called the New Hampshire state plan on
Aging research by the state sponsored
committee states that by 2030
approximately oneir of New Hampshire's
population will be over
65 these two issues combined illustrate
that we have to do something much
greater to attract people especially
younger individuals and families to the
Granite State when young families look
at opportunities and compare these
opportunities between a state that
stands to support its workers and one
that delegates paid sickly time to an
employer's discretion it is obvious
which option produces a more secure
working environment an overall
environment to raise a family voting yay
on HB 590 will not only greatly benefit
over 66% of granite Staters who do not
have access to paid leave but will also
help Elevate New Hampshire's status as
an ideal employment destination and help
attract younger workers to our state
thank
you thank you for your brief and
succinct testimony any questions anyone
in the committee
room any questions online
seeing none thank you Christina I would
ask that um uh Christin Craig had submit
a written testimony uh since we're
unable to hear
her um are there any other individuals
speak no there are not all right seeing
none I'm going to close the hearing on
House Bill
well you have to wait two minutes I
guess
rule
so so representative Broody you can have
friends Ben and I sat in the cold for
how many hours on Election Day and the
snow and the cold 6 hours at
day oh Mr Mr chair yes that that day in
the snow paid off you both won yes we
K Ben and I we've know each other about
20 years now and yeah at
least the same represented the same
do Mr we're going back to 385 right
that's correct thank you
sir chairman yes could you uh let us
know how many people signed in in favor
and opposed to the uh last bill you know
I was going to read it representative S
I probably should have but there's 75
names here um
wow numbers work so I will tell you that
uh a vast majority of them were u in
um but I
I we'll have it in I'm happy to read
that for you pardon Christin I'm happy
to read that for you um chair
infantine for 590 there were
256 supporters and 30
opposed
wow so I didn't want to have to read all
1:00
um all right we're going to have to try
to do this legally there are three bills
on the docket for 1:00 House Bill 517
FN House Bill 107 and House Bill
501 I am opening
those the hearing on both three bills
and recessing them uh for a short period
of time and going back to the original
legislation that we wanted to hear at
9:00 a.m. which is House Bill 385 FN
relative to workers compensation for
heart and lung disease and firefighters
that we had to uh move around because of
technical problems so I'm going to open
the hearing on House Bill 385 FN and I
will
recognize
uh the prime sponsor of the bill Mark
Pearson representative Pearson are you
with
us yes I am sir
you're you're recognized to speak thank
you and before I read my testimony I
would like to give a big shout out to
Christina Dyer she also works for the
committee I chair and wow thank you so
much this is representative Mark Pearson
I re uh represent Rockingham County 34
Atkinson Hamad Kingston and plastow I am
chairman of the health human services
and elderly affairs Committee of the
house house bill 385 is the product of
and is co-sponsored by a bipartisan
group of legislators who are or were
firefighters and we added a formal
Federal Marshall the former Speaker of
the House for good measure I was a
volunteer firefighter in lemonster
Massachusetts half a century ago but
I've kept up with the fire service as a
fire buff and as the proud father of a
Manchester fire Lieutenant Steph Pearson
who is also a legislator representing
Derry I hang out at fire stations I go
to fires and sometimes I even get asked
to help humping
hose my career path however was not in
the fire service I was uh ordained in
1974 and in nearly half a century of
ordained Ministry I've had many
firefighters at as parishioners I can
think of several who died young with a
few it would be difficult to determine
in their cases whether their untimely
deaths were from a career of being
exposed to toxic smoke from burning
buildings or from being chain smokers
and being
overweight however I also had some
firefighter parishioners who never
smoked who kept themselves in great
shape and yet they came down with heart
and lung or lung disease or both while
their siblings did not what was the
difference in their lives was it the
toxic smoke they sucked in over their
professional careers manifesting itself
in disease in some cases decades
afterwards I will leave to the people I
hope will have come back to testify
after me to support the growing
scientific data but I'll leave you with
this it's a cliche but it's ever so true
firefighters run into the burning
buildings everyone else is running out
of and even with their air packs they
suck in over a career Untold n amount of
toxins that are known to cause both
heart and lung disease they are not
firefighters for the money anymore than
we are legislators for the money for
them as well as for us it's a calling
sometimes their disease manifests
quickly and they have to take early
retirement for which workers
compensation is available but some of
them present with the illness years
afterwards this bill would give such
people the same break whenever there's
an injury or a line of duty death and in
fact on many other occasions we thank
firefighters for their service let's
also thank them by removing an
artificial date Beyond which heart and
lung diseases will no longer be covered
by workers comp and that is my testimony
uh Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you for your testimony
representative any questions for the
online seeing none any questions for the
members here in the committee
room uh representative I have a question
for you um I did uh I can't recall
because I get I get old whe whether the
last time I was in the legislature I
thought this passed
um and and it passed and it had this
look back and from what I understand uh
the first claim that was made U by a
firefighter uh for a workers
compensation um based on this bill it
was denied and that's why you're coming
back not you but the the organization is
coming back to make the changes um
because there was a fiveyear I believe
look back period could you explain this
to me um and
in why we need to totally
eliminate the look back period um you
know there's a lot of things in the
industry where you know kids are are
tested for lead and it becomes the the
Baseline and then they look to see what
happens
um you
know
why are you trying to get rid of any
kind of look back or Baseline
testing Mr chairman I can give you a
broad answer because sometimes things
present years afterwards but for a more
technical answer I am hoping that uh a
co-sponsor of this bill fire lieutenant
and representative Stephen Pearson is in
this meeting and he can provide more
technical
information all right thank you very
much representative pearon yes sir see
no other questions I will recognize uh
representative Pearson representative
us yes I am can you hear me yes we can
wonderful thank you I thank the
committee um for allowing me to speak
today I'm I'm gonna I'm going to touch
on a little bit of the of the technical
part of this I'm not going to get into
the get overly technical because I don't
think it it really it just confuses the
matter so um incidentally January was
firefighter cancer awareness month which
um which is something that has really
come onto the Forefront in the in the
fire service in 2019 75% of all of the
names that were added to the Fallen
Firefighters Memorial in Colorado
Springs were firefighters who died of
Occupational
cancer you know we we're exposed as
firefighters as as my father was nice
enough to to give me the the interlude
there um we're exposed to a plethora of
stuff you know while we work arenic
asbest Benzene cadmium diesel exhaust
from alahh silica vyl chloride and now
which uh unfortunately we're learning
that firefighting foam also is is become
a these are known carcinogens this isn't
even the list of suspected
carcinogens so when you look at the
those types of exposures the next
question really begs is okay well what
does that mean as far as the general
population so when you look at the the
the testing that's been done over the
years and in the gobs of data that exist
tracking disease of all types you notice
that there's some things that stand out
esophageal cancer you're 1.1 times
greater leukemia 1.1 times greater colon
cancer 1.2 prostate 1.2 brain cancer 1.3
non hutkins lipoma one and a half times
greater at risk um melanoma one and a
half times greater at risk
meso yeah it's a mouthful mesom two
times the risk testicular cancer which
is one of the big biggest ones well over
two times likely more likely to develop
cancer than the general population so
this is certainly glowing data that
comes out of this when you look at
cancer in a
comparison in a comparison U format
simply because as we all know the
general population gets cancer as well
it's not unique to Firefighters so one
of the things that has also happened in
where this age
elimination comes into into play
honestly has to do with the way that the
state of New
Hampshire has restructured the pension
system and I know you'd think well wait
a minute what does that have to do with
anything and I'll explain it to you when
you get out of high
school you know at this day and age
you're you're either you may do a career
in the military you may go to college
either way but when you're done with
that period of your life you enter the
fire academy you become trained you
become an EMT you go through the
certification processes that are
necessary to join this profession
and that put you at a in a certain age
window so
now where for the predominancy of the
fire service in the state of New
Hampshire professional firefighters
would retire between the ages of like 53
and 55 in order to qualify for a three
quter
pension you're working till
65 that that's going to become for
anybody that was hired after 2011 they
will be working till they're 65 so so at
a minimum you have to do 25 years so
when you look at the math the simple
math here 65 might have worked when you
got out of the firefighting profession
at 53 years old because there's a Time
window there from when you stopped being
exposed
until time progressed but if you're
working till 65 if 65 becomes the cut
off it basically says Hey when it's it's
like the tail light warranty as soon as
you leave the profession that's it and
you know
we've I know that seems strange that
that becomes a factor but it really does
matter when when we've pushed out these
careers and you know when
you're so now because of that now the
fire service has taken a significant
movement towards prevention and Care
cancer awareness like I said January was
firefighter cancer awareness
month and focusing on firefighter cancer
within the profession is great to limit
and reduce or attempt to reduce
exposures and we've recognized a lot of
areas where that is occurring but it
doesn't eliminate the substantial risk
that
exists so that's that's basically to
answer the question that you asked Mr
chairman as far as why the 65 age really
needs to come out of this is because
we're working up until that point now
and these cancers are not necessarily
manifesting themselves in people within
that time frame
so that's really the in my eyes the
predominant reason why this this needs
to go away when there's just
overwhelming data and evidence that that
firefighters develop cancer at a much
population all right thank you for your
testimony um I think that's the end um
quite sure are you still there with US
Representative which representative are
you referring too okay I wasn't sure if
we lost you or not any questions for the
representative in the committee
online I don't see any hands up thank
you very much for your testimony now
calling on Brian will professional
firefighters of New Hampshire um and
congratulations Brian uh getting your
second uh inoculation today
vaccine thank you very much Mr chairman
can you hear me okay yes we can just a
little louder please if you could sure
uh I appreciate you all having me on uh
chairman and uh members of the committee
my name is Brian will uh I serve as the
Pres uh president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire and I'm
also a captain for the city of
Portsmouth fire department uh on behalf
of the 42 local unions and approximately
2,000 active and retired professional
firefighters and paramedics that I
represent I'm providing testimony and
support of HB 385 FN uh relative to
workers compensation for heart and lung
disease and
firefighters It is Well documented that
throughout the course of their Duty
firefighters are subject uh subjected to
a number of Occupational hazards that
clearly take a toll on the human body
the routine exposure to high physical
and emotional stress heat and
cancer-causing
carcinogens makes it far more likely
that a firefighter will develop
cardiovascular disease lung disease or
cancer the American Heart Association
cites sudden cardiac death as the
leading cause of death for firefighters
at approximately 45% of all job related
deaths repeated injury as a result of
physical strain emotional stress or
exposure to carcinogens or infectious
diseases have a cumulative effect on the
human body that increases the
firefighter's risk of cardiovascular
disease moreover the National Institute
of Occupational Safety and Health's most
recent study shows that firefighters
uh at least at a 14% increased risk uh
of dying from cancer as opposed to the
general population so you heard
testimony from Representative Steve
Pearson who mentioned all those um
different cancer
diagnosises and uh the increase as
opposed to the general population and uh
just to reiterate that that total is a
14% increase risk uh which is
staggering the Hazardous nature of the
fire service industry is it's never been
disputed and in fact the state of New
Hampshire has already recognized the
serious nature and sometimes
catastrophic effects of this profession
by adopting legislation that states when
a firefighter is diagnosed with heart
lung or cancer disease is presumed to
have been occupationally related HB 385
would simply eliminate that sunset
provision um that this benefit would not
continue past the firefighter's 65th
birthday firefighters routinely risk
their lives to protect the citizens and
the communities they serve and are
oftentimes rewarded with cardiovascular
disease pulmonary illness or a cancer
diagnosis for their efforts it is
incumbent upon us to show these
firefighters that we will always have
their back for the service they provide
to this great state and not just until
they turn
65 I respectfully ask for the
committee's full support of HB 385 and
uh I'm happy to entertain any questions
you may have of
me thank you any questions for the
speaker in the committee
online uh Brian I have a question for
you I'm just
reading the uh I'm reading this 281 a17
and quite frankly before I started
reading this I thought you were trying
to get rid of the fiveyear there there
there's two dates okay you talk about
here in the legislation
um Rel
repeal the relative to the length of
time of the presumption of heart or lung
disease in members of the fire
department there's no debate here uh nor
was there believe years ago that
firefighters uh are have great
propensity for cancer uh than others
that's why this law was passed uh there
are two things that I see in the
law uh a retired firefighter who agrees
to submit to a physical examination
request by a city town or Precinct shall
have the benefit of the prim of facial
presumption only during the period of
time of 5 Years From the effective date
of the firefighter's retirement that is
that the sub the the item you want to um
extend because you say C and I don't see
uh I see the benefit of RSA shall not
continue in effect Beyond one month
after a call volunteer or permanent
firefighter reaches his or her 65th
birthday that's the item you want to
change correct
uh correct sir and I would defer to the
um Prime sponsor of the bill but as I
understand it uh it would be 281a 17 C
that second one that you mentioned okay
I'm not trying to be combative I'm just
trying to understand what you're asking
me to pass you stated that firefighters
now with a new pension have to serve
until 65 years of age
correct um so that I believe what
representative uh Steve Pearson was
referring to uh is new firefighters with
a change of the retirement system have
to work longer into their uh careers
both in age and uh years of service so
um for some firefighters uh so so the
retirement system does not mandate that
they have to work until age 65 uh
however with the changes in the
retirement system in order for them to
receive
a uh pension that they would have
received back in 2011 they have to work
uh longer into their careers um which
for many folks uh as the representative
mentioned could be age 65 um so when you
look back on uh protecting these
firefighters past that age um it's
looking at trying to protect them into
the early years of their
retirement I hope that answers your
it is my understanding that all workers
compensation in the state of New
Hampshire terminates at age 65 and at
that
point
um other benefits um whether they be
Medicare Medicaid other mechanisms fall
into play which is why this was I
believe
terminated at
65 you are asking this
be
appealed so there is
no termination of workers compensation
benefits till
death correct
sir again I would defer to the to the
prime sponsor of the bill to correct me
on that uh if I'm
misinformed understood are there any
speaker okay cenan thank you very
much the last individual I had have to
to speak at least on my my sheets was uh
Warner horn a member of the public is in
us good afternoon Mr chairman I hope you
can hear me we can good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the labor committee
for the record my name is Warner horn I
am from Franklin I was the original
co-spon I was the original Prime sponsor
for this legislation last
year uh we sadly lost it to the coid
crisis and representative Pearson has
kindly resubmitted it on my
behalf and I can definitely clarify for
the Chairman's question earlier that the
goal of this legislation is to repeal
the age cap for the death benefit
specifically uh here in Franklin we lost
a firefighter some years ago who was
70 there's no doubt that his death was
directly linked to his fire service
career he was a call firefighter for
many many years here in Franklin and uh
when he passed he passed very quickly
about 90 days or so from diagnosis to
his passing and his family was unable to
collect on a death benefit through
workers comp because of his Advanced
age um the legislation seeks to repeal
the age cap at 65 if a firefighter
retires at 53 they have 5 years to
establish that there is a condition
connected to their service if a
firefighter chooses to retire at 63 then
they only have two years to establish
that their illness
is tied to their fire service um this is
kind of an injustice in my view because
in New Hampshire especially Northern New
Hampshire and Western New Hampshire we
are increasing reliant on firefighters
deeper into their
lives and to say that they can't get
this death benefit or their families
actually their families specifically are
the ones who would be receiving this
death benefit um it does not seem right
to me uh even if you are a 70-year old
firefighter and you are outside of the
building on a pumper truck if the wind
takes that smoke coming from the
building and changes Direction suddenly
and pushes it through the path of the
pumper they can be exposed to those
toxic fumes um because they're not
wearing an air pack when they're on the
Pumpers
um so the fiveyear period is not
anything that I'm see that would be
changed by this legislation this
legislation is specifically targeting
whether the death benefit would be cut
off at 65 and with that I'm happy to
committee any questions for the speaker
um in the committee
online um Mr uh horn I have a question
would you please reiterate the example
you gave of
Franklin the firefighter who passed away
and why he wasn't able to
collect Captain Robert Brown passed away
way at the 70 years
is his death it's unlik it's Unthinkable
that his death wouldn't be connected to
his fire service he passed away from
cancer um diagnosis to death was about
days because he was 70 he would his
family was unable to collect on a death
benefit through workers comp okay could
you please explain what you mean by
death benefit
the the section that we're talking about
here is um specific to workers comp and
the death benefit if somebody passes
away from heart or lung
conditions so this isn't a disability
issue got me totally confused so you
read from sub paragraph C the benefits
of RSA 281 a 7
one shall not continue in effect Beyond
one month after a call volunteer a
permanent firefighter reaches his six
his or her 65th birthday and the chapter
is exclusive
to
um the heart and lung conditions and the
death
benefit I'm just confused I'm not again
I'm not trying to be combative here the
only death benefit provided in a workers
compensation
policy is I believe uh $110,000 burial
fee burial payment the only other
benefit you're talking about is either
medical or Indemnity which is loss of
to as I as I understood it from the fire
chief of Franklin uh when he was fire
chief
uh the the phrasing he used was the
family wasn't eligible for the death
benefit because of virtue of his age and
they cited this chapter this sub
paragraph C
specifically so that's the part of this
repealed okay uh thank you for teson any
other
questions any other questions
online see none thank thank you for your
testimony um sir we have any additional
speakers on House Bill 385 in the
queue I do not see anyone and that is
all I
have okay thank you um the other
individuals who um representative Jeff
goalie uh has written for support uh
Christina
cerella uh insurance department is
neutral Glenn bracket uh men and women
of New Hampshire F CIO is signed in for
support Tony lebrand in support Cordell
Johnson New Hampshire Municipal
Association
opposed Chief Jon Jones Association of
Fire Chiefs support Eric Rathburn is
himself support see no other um
individuals wishing to testify on behalf
of this bill I will close a hearing on
House Bill 385 FN and move on to the
1:00 hearings
I'm going to open the he uh re reconvene
the hearing on House Bill 501
establishing a minimum rate for adjunct
facility of the University system of New
Hampshire and Community College system
the you know I don't see you here uh but
is it appropriate to call on
representative kahill were you expecting
to introduce this yeah yes indeed I was
uh Mr
chairman you and you're not sitting in
the chair you're sitting in the
testimony
chair no uh no I'm sitting uh I'm
sitting in my in a spare bedroom at home
but I will sit I will sit here it looks
like the
L that's a uh that's a Ply cheap plywood
closet behind
me um anyway I am uh representative
Michael kahill from the Rockingham 7 new
fields and New Market and we are here
today to discuss HB
501 um establishing a minimum pay rate
for adjunct faculty the university
system of New Hampshire and Community
College of New Hampshire uh they are
they they do have a union and they are
of course public employees and their
option they can't strike or anything
like this but they've been in
negotiations which have gone nowhere
very actually without a contract and
they not getting much assistance with
the uh with the University or with the
community college system so uh I bring
it to your attention I'm going to share
and
oops here we go so we can see that
there's an really a disproportionate
number of adjunct versus full-time
faculty so full-time faculty are people
who have additional responsibilities
Beyond representative kill um we're not
seeing the numbers we're seeing the file
um uh oh oh okay wait you're not seeing
the number okay see faculty numbers HP
501 it just isn't open uh oh hold
open mine
bad how's
that uh let me get may do another screen
share
sorry are we are we there
now uh no it doesn't look like the
screen has shared just yet okay but to
right
um are we there
now uh yes we can see them thank you oh
thank you okay
so uh the the uh community college
system and like other universities and
schools of Higher Learning are relying
heavily on
adjunct uh in in part because they're
cheaper uh they don't get benefits uh
they're only paid when they teach if
they're if they class is canceled due to
short enrollment or something they don't
get paid and they are paid substantially
less than the full-time faculty so what
we're asking what we're asking to do
here is to is to pay them
75% of what a full-time faculty member
would receive for class time and we
understanding that this would be you
know a considerable expense but see
here's what they're getting now the
maximum an adjunct can earn is 836 per
credit or 25 $258 for a three credit
course and whereas the full-time
teaching the same receives
$2,354 oh sorry receives $3,300 per
credit uh which is you know
substantially more than the person doing
the same work and we have students
taking these classes and they're being
taught you know by qualified people some
of them with
phds but um we we have a situation we we
want to keep tuition low but it
shouldn't be on the backs of the people
providing the instruction so it's a it's
a challenge indeed and uh we had people
behind me other people who are more
directly involved that may be able to
answer better answer questions but you
have a copy of this document and I yield
Witnesses
okay uh thank you representative kill
for your
testimony do we have any questions um on
online okay do I have any questions the
committee members in the
lob one representative turot you
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative kahill
um let me turn something off on my
computer I'm getting a feedback here
hold
on okay um is it my understanding
that are you're feeding back you're have
an
echo thank you representative kahill Mr
chairman is it my understanding that um
the University of New Hampshire system
and the Community College systems there
are professors in each one of those uh
systems and adjunct or lecturers as I
think UNH calls them and for each one of
those groups there
are uh Union collective bargaining
agreements is that correct
that is
correct did he say correct um yeah he
did say yes yes
Paul uh if that is the
case is is it your
intention that the
legislate the legislature puts into law
something that has an immediate effect
or a direct effect on collective
bargaining
agreements uh thank you for the question
representative uh it is really because
of the lack of the uh collective
bargaining agreement to be to be uh
negotiated uh that they're that they're
falling upon deaf ears that that we're
offering this bill uh because the you
know with the system that's was created
we delegated to the trustees go ahead
and run this we don't know how to run a
university just go ahead and run it but
what we have here is a situation where
people are being uh vastly underpaid for
doing the same work and basically you
know because they're an adjunct and not
a full uh faculty member and in many
other fields like the medical field for
example if you're a medical technologist
and you're working you know for a short
term you're you're paid an hourly rate
greater than that of the uh of your
peers because you're attemp and you're
not getting benefits so we have these
money
thank you Mr chairman welcome any other
questions representative Huff you're
recognize for a question thank you Mr
chair
um so is it my understanding or or not
are the adjunct folks in the union or
not in the
unions thank you representative there
are they have a union and the uh
full-time have a separate Union they
separate
cbas and
um again it's uh they have they've been
working without a contract and we will
have a person from that Union uh lined
up to speak afterwards I I believe who
might be able to give more incent to
that I also sent you the uh fact finding
report uh and so you can see what what
they're up against uh it's just uh it's
something that we wouldn't be here today
talking about this if the University
system the community college system had
been more responsive to the needs of
these uh
faculty thank you thank you any other
online is that represent of to me do you
have your hand up for a question nope
just scratching your
nose uh thank you for your testimony I
would like to call on uh representative
Bill thank you Mr chair I think my
committee is about to EXA some bills so
I'm gonna be even briefer than I was
gonna be
before um so I am here to introduce HB
517 the bill to um raise the wage for
New Hampshire workers to $115 over four
steps
uh
represent represent we're we're
referring to House Bill
501 relative to the minimum pay rate for
adjunct facility for the univ uh I'm
sorry the way the bills were listed it
looked like they were grouped together I
apologize I'm here to introduce my bill
so I'll step
away okay we will get you for that one
shortly and I know you have exact
session so we'll try to work around you
as well thank I appreciate that the next
person I have on my list to speak is
Trisha Todd tid tid Trisha
Trisha yes she
is hi hi uh my name is Trish Ed uh I am
an adjunct faculty member at Manchester
Community College I teach anatomy and
physiology um so the community college
and the University of New Hampshire both
of them are really important to our
state and our citizens because they do
give our citizens an affordable way to
get higher
education um one of the things about the
community college system is that we have
been in the last couple years really
trying to make the courses equivalent to
a four-year college so that students
have a viable option to have a two plus
two program where they can do that for
an affordable
price in doing that adjunct faculty has
the same responsibility as full-time
faculty we have the same availability to
students we have the same requirements
the same level of teaching um and we
have the same educational
requirements um as our
full-time um
equivalents but in addition to that a
lot of the adjunct faculty bring Real
World experience that brings a level of
perspective diversity in Real World um
actual work ethic into the community and
and it enriches the the college um as
well as our students making them more
ready to enter the
workforce as you can see there's a large
number of adjunct faculty at um all of
our community colleges I've taught at
Manchester Community College I've also
taught a couple classes at River
Valley um we are members of that
Community we know our students we know
our fellow faculty members we attend
faculty meetings we do all of the same
things that our full-time faculty
members do um but we're doing that for a
fraction of the price
um it still would be a cost a
cost-saving
measure um even raising the per hour the
per credit hour pay uh because you're
only paying for the work that's actually
done as opposed to a general salary
um but there needs to be a minimum just
like there's a minimum wage requirement
I I I heard the beginning there were a
couple questions about the union and
about that collective
bargaining as representative Cahill
mentioned we haven't been really
successful on that collective bargaining
um like unlike some other unions that
have that ability to to strike and to do
other things we don't really have that
um so it's just conversations going back
and forth on that Collective bargain
and I've been teaching as an adjunct
for uh like over over six years now and
I don't think I've ever worked under a
current contract
um we're back I think it's three or four
years where the contracts are are being
approved um so I actually have never
worked under a contract um and that
that's a little bit frustrating you know
there's no um no stability um in the job
and they're they're definitely could be
a little bit more of that um so that's
all that I have thank you for your
time thank you tra any questions in the
uh L for Trisha yes representative turot
you're recognized for question thank you
Mr chairman thank you for the testimony
uh Trisha uh couple questions uh are you
a member of the whatever the Union uh I
don't know the exact name of Union but
are you a member of it and pay paying
IND do to that Union Yes I am a member
of that Union it's the sa um SEIU sea um
we're at chapter
32 follow up Mr chair follow
up I'll ask you a variation of what I
asked representative kahill why do you
believe it's the legisl legislator's
responsibility if you have a union and
you pay dues to that Union why is it the
responsibility of the legislature to
develop
laws uh to solve a a section of your
collective bargaining
agreement okay thank you that's a great
question um I see it more as kind of
like having the federal minimum wage um
that there needs to be a basement where
we can then negotiate from um and right
now the the basement isn't really there
um as far as what they're they're
talking about um and then you can also
see the lack of success of what's been
going on with those Communications um in
the collective bargaining and I haven't
been involved myself in the collective
bargaining um I believe that there's
another um another person who's going to
be testifying Steve that that could
probably talk better to to those
specifics thank you representative
Callum did I see your hand
raised I don't know if I can hear me
from I'm going to grab you just a moment
we're going to grab a microphone for the
representative
[Music]
represent Callum you recognize got
question thank you Mr Speaker
union
and if
um
75% less than your
regular
instructors is a good
number then that's 25% less
than than regular employe
employment why is is not 25% greater a a
good
number we'd always love to get more
money right um but there are some
differences between adjunct faculty and
full-time faculty um adjunct faculty
would have more um more time as far as
the advising with students um adjunct
faculty definitely do advising we have
office hours we meet with students but
adjunct uh full-time faculty have
additional administrative duties and I
believe that that would be the the
difference thank you for you taking my
question
yeah for the
speaker seeing n thank you very much for
your testimony thank you like call Jacob
Bennett and after Mr Bennett
Stephen barill but Mr Bennett are you
I see your I am here I am here you're
recognized to speak thank you very much
um I sent uh uh this testimony earlier
today uh along with some data that I'll
mention in the testimony um as well as
some uh reports from uh other other
organizations um that that I hope help
fill in some of the the gaps here um but
I'll just read from the statement and
then hope uh answer any questions if
there are
any uh thank you to the committee for
hearing this testimony my name is Jacob
Bennett and I represent myself today in
documentation submitted to the committee
prior to this hearing I provided
research I conducted into adjunct wages
and determinations across the university
system of New Hampshire and I also
submitted reports produced by the US
government office of accountability and
the national Center for educational
statistics US House committee on
education and the workforce and the uh
University of Southern California
rossier School of education's pus Center
for higher education I provide these
documents to bolster my testimony on HB
501 which I support for the sake of full
disclosure I would like to note that I
currently employed as an adjunct in the
education department at UNH and
conducted the research described uh in
in this testimony while funded to pursue
my doctorate in the same department at
the time I initiated that research uh
into wages and determinations I was also
serving as a non-voting graduate student
representative to the university system
of New Hampshire Board of
Trustees for my research I obtained
adjunct wage data from academic year
2018 and 19 for faculty at Granite State
College Keen State College Plymouth
State University and University of New
Hampshire the data I received from the
four institutions is not uniform but I
created tables that provide comparable
snapshots from that Academic Year in
regard to average wages paid to faculty
determined by the institutions to to be
adjunct or part-time at an institution
offering and this is for context at an
institution offering four credit hour
courses on average uh part-time is
typically defined as no more than eight
credit hours per term or semester or
0.50 full-time
equivalency um that is uh below the uh
the the rate or the equivalency that
would require
benefits um the tables I provided do not
of course reflect discussions about the
data which included inquiry through
offices of provosts and human resources
at each of the four institutions as well
as with staff in the offices of General
Council and human resources at the
University system of New Hampshire nor
do they indicate the lack of resources
at some component institutions devoted
to the professional development of
adjunct faculty um just for context
again at UNH for instance there are
plentiful examples of Faculty
development programs described in
materials posted to the pages of the
office of the Provost and the office of
Engagement and faculty development but
few devoted or even available to adun
faculty development of these faculty is
largely left to departments themselves
fighting for resources in a low
Appropriations and therefore cost-saving
and revenue seeking
environment it is unclear whether the
data from Plymouth State and Keen State
include faculty covered by collective
bargaining agreements in place uh and
maybe I should pause for a moment here
and say that uh the uh uh presence of
collective bargaining agreements uh
across the university system of New
Hampshire is only in place for adjunct
faculty at State and Keen State not at
UNH and not at Granite State um unlike
in the community college system of New
Hampshire which has a much broader uh
coverage uh uh under Union um
representation um so there's that
stipulation at Keen the collective
bargaining agreement stipulates that the
adjunct faculty member becomes a member
of the bargaining unit when he or she
starts her his or her fifth semester of
teaching um which is why uh I I I'm not
sure if the data I received includes
unionized or non unionized members or
non-members uh similar situation at
Plymouth uh they call them teaching
lecturers but it's same situation there
are folks who are covered by the CBA and
folks who are not and I don't know if
the data that I provided uh dis uh
distinguishes between those different
groups um adjuncts again at UNH in
Granite State are not covered by any
CBA um in any case I do not believe that
any adjunct pay is tied to any of this
internally available data so there are
wage tables included in those uh
collective bargaining agreements um I do
not believe that at Plymouth for
instance or Keen that uh the non-member
adjunct wages are tied to this data or
uh or these wage schedules which are
negotiated in the
contract in the end my findings lead to
a conclusion that the wage
determinations for adjunct faculty
outside of CBA coverage are arbitrary
and detached from any form of internal
or external data such as an industry or
market Standard or prevailing wages for
full-time faculty in a teaching
intensive appointments we heard uh just
before uh the distinction between
full-time faculty and part-time faculty
um in the non- tene uh track uh
full-time faculty uh appointment it's
typically teaching intensive but with
some service
expectations um uh with a tenure track
uh or tenure position there would also
be research expectations so there is a
distinction between full-time faculty uh
who are tenured and those who are not to
be fair to the institutions the reason
for the of external data comparison is
frankly quite simple there are no
reliable or standardized data to which
an institution may turn when determining
adjunct faculty wages the integrated
post-secondary Education data systems
which is housed under the national
Center for Education Sciences does not
require reporting of adjunct wage data
in the way that it requires reporting of
wage data for full-time faculty on and
off the 10e track uh this of course is
beyond the remit of the New Hampshire
general court because the statutes and
policies that guide and require iPads
reporting are functions and
responsibilities of the US Senate house
and department of education however it
is within the remit of the New Hampshire
General Court I believe to require
regular and standardized reporting of
wage data from the institutions within
the public higher education systems
including usnh and
ccsnh regarding usnh there's language
requiring the public higher education
study committee to report annually on
financing of public higher education and
any other areas which will act as a
guide to the legislature and trustees in
formulating policies for the future
regarding ccsnh there's language
requiring annual reporting and review of
system programs and costs as well as any
other information detailed in the
written
report turning to the language of HP 501
I urge the following amendments uh I
support the bill but I am offering some
amendments um which are noted in red in
the testimony I've provided um again
this is uh making distinction between
full-time faculty overall and full-time
faculty on teaching intensive
appointments because I think that's the
appropriate comparison when talking
about adjunct
pay uh I won't read the the the actual
language here but that's the main idea
is I've added language that suggests
that if we are going to say
75% uh uh of the average salary of
full-time faculty we should be speaking
about full-time faculty with teaching
intensive appointments um as that seems
the most uh um reasonable comparison um
I make that that suggestion for
Amendment for both uh uh rsas for the US
NH and ccsnh uh statutes um separate
from the establishment of minimum salary
requirements and perhaps this would
require a separate bill I don't know um
I would I would urge something uh along
the lines of University and Community
College systems faculty wage reporting
for purposes of public accountability um
and I would urge amendment of RSA 187a
28c or other existing statutes to
require regular and standardized
reporting of all faculty and staff wages
across usnh and I would recommend
amending RSA 188 f11
uh or other existing statutes to require
regular and standardized reporting of
all faculty and staff wages across
ccsnh uh respectfully submitted uh my
name is Jacob Bennett again representing
myself happy to take any
questions any
questions thank you Mr Ben any questions
online seeing none questions of the
members in the
um uh in the hearing room I I see
representative nun do you have a
question thank you Mr chairman uh and
thank you for your testimony uh I have a
a sort of a specific question for you
sir um sure uh all of all the adjunct
faculty are part of collective
bargaining unit uh and that unit is
supported by a union in
agreement um what steps have the members
of the bargaining unit
taken themselves to to alleviate this
situation with the
Union so I want to clarify again that
um across the community college system
uh of New Hampshire there are bargaining
units for adjunct faculty I believe at
every single campus across the
university system of New Hampshire there
are collective bargaining agreements in
place covering adjuncts only at Kean
State and at Plymouth State this is not
the case at Granite State and this is
not the case at
UNH um to the to the question uh this is
it so the question is uh have folks in
these units I'm not in any of those
units so I can't answer the question
from experience but it seems like the
question is why don't the unions do this
why are you asking the legislature and I
think that this has been answered in the
in in this form which is that the
existence of uh uh minimum wage does not
preclude unions from bargaining over
wages uh people who are in unions
outside of an academic context are
bargaining over wages and there is a a a
federal mandate for a minimum wage so
this law is not bizarre or anomalous in
in in its request I
think I I think that U may have followup
sir follow up uh uh I think that you
misunderstood my question I'm trying
perhaps did I'm trying to get at the
steps that the members of the bargaining
unit what steps have they taken to try
me again I not in any I am an adjunct at
UNH I do not belong to any of these
collective bargaining units uh so I
can't answer that question thank you
very I believe that Steve B barill who
is speaking after may be able to answer
that I app I appreciate thank you very
much thank you thank you I have a few
more questions representative seaworth
and then Tumi representative seaworth
you thank you Mr
chairman my
question relates to something you just
said in the previous response you made a
comparison um
between wages that are collectively
bargained and the statutory minimum
wage I am
wondering if you are aware of
other occupations or specific duties
that have a minimum
wage specified for them in state law so
employer are there other public employes
that have minimum wages specified for
them in
law
um not to my knowledge
no but I also don't know of any other
Industries in especially speaking in in
a public context where profession
professionals uh again many faculty have
either a master's or a doctorate are
paid at A Cut Rate to provide the same
exact service that their peers who are
on different contracts are paid so uh
this this bill would seek to rec that I
believe um regardless of whether there
are other statutes in other places that
do the same
thing thank you I have two more
questions for you representative Tumi
and then representative berui
representative Tumi you recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman uh um Mr
Bennett uh a question about this is
going to be a little bit tough because
all courses are different I mean if
you're teaching English you're teaching
art it's quite different but uh I know
that a Adjunct professor would have to
create a course a syllabus would have to
actually go to the class and and spend
time with the students and would have to
go home and then read uh you know
material or or and create marks and and
do administrated work how many hours
does a would would a typical professor
course uh I don't know that I can answer
that question I've taught uh first year
writing courses and first year
literature courses I've taught
intermediate literature and writing
courses I've taught graduate level
education courses uh it depends on the
number of students in the class it
depends on the kinds of assignments that
are uh that are given in the class which
also depends on the subject and uh uh
focus of the class um I don't I don't
really have a good answer for that and
it depends on the individual as well
some people are slower readers and
greaters than others um it's it's a hard
question to answer I think yeah I know
it would be a hard question thank you uh
for for your attempt in answering
surey you recognize representative
Broody you recognize for a question uh
thank you Mr chairman um are the adjunct
people at UNH or Plymouth were they ever
asked to join a union they ever have an
election uh the adjuncts at UNH so I am
uh I just started as an adjunct about
two weeks ago or three weeks ago um I
don't know whether there has been an
attempt before uh uh January of 2021 I
know that there is no Union uh for
adjuncts at UNH um and so I wonder what
the if the answer were yes I wonder what
what the next question would
be well if you were asked to join and
and you're not a member probably had an
election and voted not to
join I don't believe there has been an
election for any Union at UNH for
adjuncts to my knowledge thank
you any other questions for the speaker
any in the at least not in my three
weeks
there anyone online
seeing none thank you Mr Bennett for
your testimony thank you for hearing me
Mr Steph
barill myself supporting Steve are you
with
hi you are recognized to speak take
yourself off mute hello yes so if you
remove hi
so if you remove curriculum development
management tutoring contact hours in
general if we only look at the work
rated duties involved in teaching a
single class not including health
insurance or other benefits full-time
faculty are paid $99,000 for one single
class for the same work for the same
class for the same expertise an adjunct
receives 25
$258 my name is Steve barale I'm the
president of Sea's chapter 32 it's the
Adent Union though I'm representing
myself today teaching on average three
classes a semester one semester teaching
beyond the credit hour cap for adun
faculty and I signed a waver stating the
overthe cap credit limit did not
constitute an offer for a full-time
position I'm not the only adject to
assign a similar statement at Great Bay
we have 34 full-time faculty roughly 200
contingent I am part of that
contingent today is February
4th um I'm not going to pay rent until
February 12th it was obviously due four
days ago this is the same conversation I
have with my landlord three times a year
internet services cost me roughly un
unreimbursed $150 a month this is a
service I cannot do without because even
before the pandemic I needed access to
Student Records student assignments and
email email on a daily basis and you can
imagine now with the need for even
zooier internet speeds the that bill is
consistently paid late as
well over the past five years I've been
on food stamps heating assistance rent
assistance have visited on multiple
occasions the local food bank and I was
informed when I first started I should
simply consider those state and federal
programs as a portion of my overall
pay I own a car that is sat in the
driveway for a year because I have not
been able to afford the repairs my teeth
are falling out of my mouth and I cannot
afford to see a dentist I am one of
hundreds I am consistently good at my
job I serve on the faculty forum and
part of the Great Bay Community College
presidential search committee I've even
been recently asked to speak at Great
Bay's all college meeting all of which I
do for free because I believe in great
Bay's Mission student success teaching
Excellence exceptional workplace culture
creativity inquisitiveness community and
Civic engagement diversity citizenship
and
sustainability as I said I am good at my
job but I could be so much better if I
was not worried about whether or not my
landlord will one day simply throw us
out onto the
street my attention would not be split
between three to four colleges all
across new New England sometimes
communting hours between campuses time
that would be better spent with students
preparing our state's future
Workforce in 2015 the state restored
$5.5 million to the ccsnh budget and in
spite of the money laid off faculty they
did increase the vice Chancellor's and
Chancellor's salary for a combined an
$120,000 in 2019 ccsnh asked for 16
million the state approved and there
were again
layoffs the Investments New Hampshire
continues to make in our community
college system are not really paying off
how much longer do you think the 34
full-time falcony at Great Bay will
survive as full-time how long must they
wait for another round of layoffs and
yet ccnh continues to bemoan low
enrollment numbers Reliance upon
contingent falculty and easily firable
employees treating talented teachers
badly underpaying professionals is
industrial foolishness and budgetarily
short-sided
however this demonstrated by other
schools such as Texas Tech who have
reversed their Reliance upon the adjunct
by creating higher quality employment
for falcony you guarantee increased
enrollment increased tuition a stronger
State Workforce and a state population
with more resources HB 501 which I'm and
support of in my opinion is only the
first
step at the very least the bill will
assure a modum of budgetary oversight it
will at the very minimum allow teachers
to focus on students not whether they
will make next month's rent thank you
for your time I'll take any questions
you may have including any in regards to
union thank you your testimony do I have
any questions for the speaker on uh with
the Representatives online
representative barudi thank you Mr
chairman um se you asked for it I'll uh
I'll ask you what steps have you taken
to
organize um so I joined the union in in
2019 January of
2019 and um the next thing I did was
become president uh there was kind of an
election but nobody ran against me so it
was kind of a default and I joined the
negotiation team at that point in time
there was only one person on the
negotiation
team um I had tried to bring other
members into the
negotiation um and that worked up to a
point and now I think we're down to
about two two people on the negotiation
team and that's me and I think um one
other person um but not the original
person that began because he was he was
currently his uh contract was not
renewed
um we I have um tried to Institute a
monthly Zoom meeting which I have had
issues with uh getting technology or
people having notification about it with
emails um so that has been kind of sort
of successful to bring more people into
the
fold I will say that myself and this is
speaking personally and not as a
representative of sea chapter 32 myself
and a few others have started looking at
ibw the International Brotherhood of
Electrical
Workers that is the union the full-time
falculty is with and a couple of the
full-time falculty have actually
expressed interest in combining our two
unions so hopefully um that will be a
step in that
direction we have sea has a wonderful
lawyer I cannot um talk about him more
than than
accolades um Jake has has done us a
wonderful job but uh the negotiating
meetings have have kind of turned
stalemate I have watched um lawyers
almost tear up I never thought I'd ever
see a lawyer tear up and nobody's
talking to each other it is a total
total stalemate and we need to change
the
conversation so I don't know if that
answers your question as much as it
explains the mess we have found
ourselves
in thank
you questions for our members
online see none in the committee room
questions seeing none thank you Mr uh
barill for your testimony you're
welcome do we have any other individuals
in the queue waiting to
speak I do not see anyone with their
hand raised at the
moment okay well uh U I just said that
and now we have Tom Cronin who has
Cronin Mr Cronin you are chairman and
members of the committee my name is Tom
Cronin I'm the director of government
relations for the University system um
just before I start I know I SED up a
little late I believe the community
college system um and interim Chancellor
Susan Huard were planning to testify um
if that's the case and Susan is on the
line I would if if okay by you Mr
chairman like to defer to her um if not
I'm happy to go and and she can jump in
afterwards she is not on the line some
my knowledge you can go ahead okay
perfect in that case um I'll be very
quick uh again my name is Tom Cronin
director of government relations for the
University system um the university
system is opposed to 501 uh HP 501 and
I've submitted some written testimony
to that effect but simply wanted to
emphasize three quick points in that
testimony first as has already been
discussed the legislature has
established wages as a mandatory subject
of bargaining and for the unionized
adjunct faculty across the system we
believe the bargaining table is the
appropriate place for these
conversations um as discussed however
there are a number of adun Faculty who
are not unionized um and in that case
really a more suitable wage comparison
would be adjunct faculty teaching
similar courses at PE peer institutions
AC Ross New England and across the
country um in which in those cases
really per credit rates are driven by
market factors including demand and
professional experience in the field um
second we're concerned that as HB 501 is
drafted it would be incredibly difficult
to administer um there's no single
credit hour wage paid to full-time
faculty um at our universities
individuals teaching in different
disciplines and differ experiences and
qualifications are compensated
differently based on those
qualifications
uh and finally I think as conceded you
know at different times during this
conversation we're certainly concerned
that you know creating uh this wage
level would without a doubt have
long-term impacts on our cost to educate
our students um so with that said again
I've submitted written testimony with
some further information but we be happy
to take any
questions thank you Tom any questions
online see n oh y I do see one
representative Sullivan you recognize
for a
question thank you Mr
chairman um I assume you heard the the
testimony of the prior um uh
witness um do you find his um
uh assertion that he's basically living
in poverty to be um a believable and uh
B
acceptable uh I did hear the PRI prior
testimony um I will say I I I do not
have the the experience that that he has
spoken of or I don't have firsthand
knowledge of the experience he's spoken
of in terms of dealing with um kind of
the ongoing Union negotiations my
understanding is he is uh community
college system um adjunct faculty or or
part of their Union again I I do think
at least she's trying to get on
chancelor H were just trying to get on
who may be able to talk a little bit
more about uh his experience and some of
his testimony
thank you thank
you okay any other questions for members
uh on
Zoom seeing n any questions of our
members in
the hearing
room singan thank you Tom for your
testimony thank you all uh chair
infantine I do see Susan Huard is
actually
raised Susan wood are you with
us Susan hard
ah
name I yes Mr chairman I'm here yeah how
do you pronounce your last name please
hward hward thank you you are recognized
to speak thank you sir and thank you all
for the opportunity to testify on house
spell
501 um I am Susan Huard I'm the interim
Chancellor of the community college
system uh before taking on this role
little less than a year ago I was the
president of Manchester Community
College for 10 years and I tried to
retire at the end of that decade but I'm
learning in New Hampshire you never
really get to uh retire if there's an
opportunity to serve and so I'm back as
the chancellor until the permanent
Chancellor is hired hopefully by the 1
of July I mention my background because
I come uh before you today having not
only been a Chancellor and a college
President I've been an adjunct faculty
member a full-time faculty member and
I've taught within middle school and
high school and I I tell you this just
to indicate the depth of my
understanding about the situation we are
in I have three points that I would like
to make about this bill first uh
compensation is a mandatory topic of
bargaining and should not be in the
legislative Arena uh secondly the
proposed legislation would create a
financially unsustainable situation and
third the provision itself is unworkable
um to briefly explain each point I'd
like to uh outline for you how ccsnh is
organized from an employee grouping
standpoint there are seven colleges
within the system but we are one single
employer we have three distinct
bargaining units one for full-time
faculty one for staff and a third for
adjunct faculty uh the sea is the
exclusive bargaining representative of
the adjunct faculty and the staff
bargaining units and the full-time
faculty as you heard earlier is
represented by the New Hampshire higher
education Union which is a segment of
the IBEW Local uh
2320 as a public employer the process
for collective bargaining is prescribed
and governed by New Hampshire RSA
273a persuant to 273a it is the
obligation of the public employer and
the employee organization certified as
the exclusive bargaining representative
to negotiate in good faith on the terms
and conditions of employment uh as
defined the terms and conditions of
employment mean wages hours and other
conditions thus wages are a mandatory
subject of bargaining and one bargain on
behalf of covered employees through an
exclusive bargaining
representative it also defines the
bargaining process for both parties
management and the union if good faith
bargaining does not result in in an
agreement the next prescribed step is
mediation if the mediation fails to
result in agreement the process moves to
non-binding fact finding bringing
elements from bargaining into the
legislative Arena by either party is not
the intent of the collective bargaining
process that has been laid out for us
the legislation before you circumvents
the established bargaining process it
also if passed would establish a
mechanism that would allow either party
Union or management to engage in the
legislative process for items not
achieved through the bargaining
process seems that creating a revolving
door of bargaining parties coming before
you seeking ends that they did not
achieve in the context of a bilateral
and thorough bargaining process
undermines the
legisl well as the bargaining process
moreover compensation is one Element
among many that are typically balanced
among
uh
secondly on the topic of this being
financially
unsustainable I want to begin by saying
that we deeply value and respect the
role of A Faculty fairness and
compensation is obviously our goal so is
organizational
sustainability I've work in other states
and I literally have seen situations
where College systems put themselves out
of business because of contract element
un sustainable and I am concerned this
isn't a finan bill perhaps it would not
in itself have a direct impact on state
of course it would have a considerable
fin
impa good everyone there you go go ahead
Susan it would be a difficult one to
calculate since there's so many value uh
variables ultimately increased costs
would be borne by the state and by the
students affordability which is our
Central Mission would cease and this
bill leads to that scenario or a
significant jump in
appropriation I also fear what the
adverse effects are that this bill would
have on our students Beyond
affordability it would certainly affect
how many instructors of any kind that we
can hire it would diminish our
flexibility in developing and offering
courses and it would be particularly
harmful to our technical programs and
that would be a real loss for our
students because they benefit from
working with professionals that are
teaching them and they benefit from
small classes and flexible offerings in
terms of time so I ask you to be very
cautious about this bill for these two
reasons first because the matter does
not belong in the legisl of Arena and
secondly because it is
unsustainable finally to comment on the
specifics of HB
51 stipulates that compensation will be
based on 75% of the salary received by
full-time faculty is calculated on a per
credit hour
basis first of all we don't determine a
full-time faculty salary based on a per
credit basis the salary received by a
full-time faculty is based on a
full-time workload which includes both
instructional and non-instructional
duties some of which you've heard um
additionally uh Beyond preparing
courses uh our full-time faculty develop
curriculum they are the connection to
Industry they are the people who are
supporting and seeking specialty
accreditations that bring high quality
to our programs they are student
advisers and mentors and while I
thoroughly appreciate one of our pre
previous speakers who talked about
mentoring
students it's not something that we ask
our uh adun faculty to do I truly
appreciate that some of our faculty
engaged that way one of the challenges
for me to speak about when I speak about
our adjunct faculty is the diversity and
the range we have people such as Steve
who spoke for whom this is their primary
means of uh making a living we have
people who have taught previously and
they supplement their retirement through
working as adjunct faculty and we have
members of Industry who take it upon
themselves to help to educate the next
group of workers that are going to come
into their
professions
uh the closest comparison that we can
make in terms of pay for full-time
faculty that's comparable to adjunct
faculty is what we call overload so if a
full-time faculty member
is teaching a course beyond what we've
uh asked as their regular
load it turns out that their
compensation for that overload course is
actually slightly less than what we pay
our adjunct faculty and I have um two
examples for you um if an adjunct
faculty member is teaching a basic
accounting course he or she is going to
make about
2500 if our full-time faculty is doing
it as an overload they're going to make
about
2,200 I could also use anatomy and
physiology as an example an adjunct is
going to make uh a bit less than
4500 our full-time faculty member is
going to make about 3,800 for the same
course and I say that's the the fair
comparator because while some adun
faculty develop syllabuses at many of
our colleges it is the full-time faculty
who are developing the course outcomes
the syllabus template they're
identifying the textbook they are doing
a lot of the work and we're then Hiring
Our agent faculty in to uh teach within
that
framework so I thank you uh for your
kind attention uh ccsn does not support
this legislation but at the same time I
want to be clear that we very much value
all of our employees our faculty
part-time and full-time and our staff I
thank you so much thank you for your
testimony any questions of any members
in the committee
room seeing none any questions of the
members online representative Sullivan
question can't hear you representative
Sullivan sorry thank you Mr chairman um
Miss Huard um I'd like to um pose the
same question to you that I did to the
previous um uh witness uh do you
find the state of uh virtually poverty
that your adjuncts are some of them are
living in do you find it uh believable
acceptable representative Sullivan I I
certainly believe what um our adun
faculty member has said but as I was and
so I believe what he is saying about his
personal
circumstance and there may be other
adjunct faculty in that circumstance but
it is not a description of the
circumstance of all of our adjunct
faculty and
um it's hard for me to comment on the
second piece of it do I find it
acceptable I would like everyone I mean
the the core mission of the community
college is to help people to find uh
satis
spying uh you know jobs and make uh
adequate
salaries
um so my comment would be that I I wish
the same for this aun
faculty but if you take the situation as
they've described it
now um uh the if I say the average
facult Adent faculty within our system
teaches two courses a semester and I I
heard
what Mr barill said um by this uh by
their suggestion we would be talking if
if an adjunct taught two classes in the
fall two classes in the spring and one
in the summer I'm now actually exceeding
the salary of a full-time faculty
member and we just don't have that
Financial capacity we're in a place
where if I think about our students 67%
when we raised tuition a few years ago
by $10 we saw a decline in enrollment
and we heard because we did surveys from
students very clearly that they were
maxed
out uh New Hampshire has either the
highest uh Community College tuition in
the country or the second highest so
balancing all of these factors I have to
think about our students as well as uh
thank you representative Tumi you
recognize for a question yeah thank you
Mr chairman
uh thanks for your testimony uh I just
wondered what does a let's say a
annually um it depends
upon whether the person is an instructor
an assistant or an associate see
it give me just a moment I
um our salaries range from about
45,000 to a little over a 100,000 uh
across the uh profor at ranks what would
an average oh I'm sorry followup Mr
chairman hello right follow up thank you
um what would be the average salary of a
a professor that's been teaching for
like seven or eight years okay someone
who was teaching for seven or eight
years would
be um and I'm going to say an associate
professor representative to me just to
choose one so those are the folks that
have been there with us for a while um
probably have a master's degree um it is
going to
[Music]
be uh someplace in the mid
80s yeah that sounds about right thank
thank
you any other questions for members
online seeing none any questions are
members in the Legislative Office
Building here in the committee room all
right seeing none uh Christina are there
any additional people ready to speak me
to move yes I see um representative
Bennett
representative Horgan you're recognized
to
speak oh thank you very much I'll I'll
be I'll be brief I
actually actually was just going to uh
reason I decided to decided to log on I
apologize for like logging on belatedly
was because I I think I pulled down the
wrong option on the uh on the new the
new whizbang uh form so I was planning
not to express an opinion one way or the
other on it um but um
very strongly in favor of the other two
bills you're hearing at one o'clock and
I'm very strongly in favor of paying
people more so um especially including
ad chunk faculty professors but I think
this bill um this bill is written um
Bill's written has many flaws so I I
agree with uh you know Mr Cronin from
University system and U Chancellor hward
that uh this would the existing
of our of our excellent um our excellent
public higher education things course
they probably probably something room
will probably hear that like that the
university system and Community College
system ha might think oh this must have
something to it but no it's uh it's the
intention is good but the idea is
written is unrealistic and also having
75% of the average uh salary is
problematic first of all because um
full-time professors do a lot of work um
you know outside the classroom and and
actually unfortunately as do ad junks
but um there in fact there's some
members of The Faculty who contribute
mightily to University and Community
College system who do little of any
teaching in the classroom but also um
also it's also like the top um top uh
top professors you know there's some who
are Superstar professors you know who
bring in lots of you know who uh make
very high salaries and you can say
whether or not that's fair or unfair but
there are are some of those and most of
them bring in uh many of them often
bring in a lot of revenue from from
other sources so that's uh so I
certainly think the idea of paying Ed
junk professors more is a good one in
principle and we should be paying
everyone a lot more than they are um
probably including us you know maybe
they should give us a raise to $125 a
year or something but that's uh I'm in
favor of high wages in general including
the adjunct professors by I I sort of
feel this bill is not workable and um if
I if I navigated the form correctly I
would have not express opinion one way
or the other because I do uh very much
respect the three sponsors um and I
totally uh I totally uh support the
larger effort that's part of I think
this particular bill has has some issues
and um is probably uh certainly not
certainly certainly uh passing it would
be a bad idea I mean might you might
want to you want feel like raining and
studying the issue that'd be good but
probably don't want to do that given uh
just the way things are here in the New
Hampshire house so that that's what I
that's I wanted to say I'm a little bit
embarrassed U and the other two minimum
wage bills I totally support him I think
even 2250 is not excessive but that's
not so I just want to be the record I
support the other two pills very
strongly but not this one and um this
probably unnecessary because probably
nobody is actually going to do it's
unclear who of anybody aside from the
chair X it gets to see these long lists
of people who signed in but I still
thought I should do so I should log in
and like retreat from what I what I said
earlier today when I was filling out the
form so um thank you very much and I was
not as brief as I was hoping would be
but thanks if I have any questions
you're welcome to ask them thank you
representative Oregon we will be
addressing the other Bill shortly if you
want to log on in a few
minutes go to I might try to log on so
yes I'm totally in favor of paying
people more I think that's good for the
economy and including ad junk back a
little just as buil the way it works is
kind of problematic so thank thank you
representative Horgan Christina the
other
individual uh so it looks like uh Jacob
Bennet and Stephen barill um I don't
know if they already spoke but they both
have their hands up Jacob Bennett has
spoken so aside from those two who have
re raised their hands um there is no one
else okay thank you very much seeing no
other I'm going to Clos the hearing on
well before I close the hearing there
were 35 people who who signed in
supporting to uh opposed and one neutral
the neutral was the Department of Labor
I
believe ask me uh yeah um so um it was
not Department of Labor I apologize so
I'm going to close the hearing on House
Bill 501 and move quickly to House
Bill
107 House Bill 107 is in regards to
increasing the minimum wage it is
sponsored by representative
zus
sadus is anyone I have no one signed up
to introduce the bill I have two signed
up opposed do we have any representative
to um introduce House Bill
107 I believe representative sopus is
here thank you I apologize for the Mis
pronunciation representative
thank you for joining
us can you hear me yes we can please
you're workiz to speak on your bill um
my name is Katherine sfus I represent
Nashville w s and of all days in your
infinite wisdom you scheduled the
minimum wage bills when they're
newsworthy from Co Coast to Coast
um today s Seattle's bill became an
active Bill to raise the minimum wage to
15 an hour and in the last election um
Florida raised their minimum wage to $15
an hour the minimum wage came about in
1938 from uh Franklin delanor Roosevelt
after the Great Depression from the Fair
Labor Standard um act and it was a a
robust 25 cents an hour
hour and um he had he made a statement
then and said no business which Depends
for its existence on paying less than
living wages to its workers has any
right to continue in this
country um
so for
me I started my first job when I was 14
and that was in
1969 minimum minimum wage was less than
$2 an hour and here we are in
2021 and it's gone up to
$725 an hour and I just think it's
ludicrous for the um adjusted for what
it should be in the
30s um there's a the wage stagnation for
the poor is is just incredibly awful and
the reason why I chose
2250 is because I
Express that the despair of the
poor and this last year there was no
plans for this pandemic there was no
plans for the uh winter for how people
were going to get through there's just
people are hurting really really bad and
some of the food banks have been out of
food and all the state could come up
with
um in the fall was uh moving homeless
people off of the
courthouse um and put them back by the
river the homeless so that's why I I
want to
encourage um a a bro broad robust
discussion about what the minimum wage
should be it does the research is there
that Rising the minimum raising the
minimum wage does
not depress the economy it does not harm
businesses I want to know for the cares
act money that the governor received how
much of that went to small businesses
our small businesses are Hur hurting
they're hurting bad and
um yet we persist in giving tax credit
tax cuts to the big businesses that
don't often work in New Hampshire but
they have um their headquarters here and
so where is all of this money and I
think it should come down to Grants for
small um businesses and we need to talk
seriously
about not a minimum wage but how uh
living wage can be better for New
Hampshire and I just implore
you I know that this is asking for the
world in this bill because there's no
lag and there's no staggered thing a
date of um starting but what I want you
to know is there's people out there in
this state who work hard they work so
hard and they're hungry they're hungry
they're cold and people are isolated
because of the pandemic and we need to
as a legislature to help them and to
help our communities and that's what I
um have for you today and I'm um open
for all the questions that I know are
going to come and I already know what
does that conclude your testimony
representative yes all right well thank
you very much do we have any questions
for the representative uh on Zoom from
committee seeing none thank you any I'll
speak if I may yes representative SM I'm
sorry I didn't see you that's okay I was
a little slow um hello uh representative
sakas it's good to see you um have you
used the living wage calculator that's
available online I think MIT has done
it um no but I did read a research
article over the summer that it would be
2250 an hour yeah it's there's no
question about it if you if you look at
the living wage calculator they actually
can break it down to nasua and if you
look at it you'll see that they don't
even have that the the costs are crazy
out of line with with what's real here
on the ground uh the other thing is um
you're familiar with um places like
Walmart that do not pay enough for their
workers to stay off um you know
government assistance yes yes yes called
The Working Poor these are the people
that you're talking about going to the
food banks yes those are the people in
in my um in my ward yeah yes yeah W
Seven's in trouble thank you very much
thank you Mr Mr chairman
you're welcome any additional
questions seeing none thank you
representative I have two other speakers
signed up to speak the first is
representative how huff and Then
followed by Henry Vu representative Huff
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Greg Huff I'm rep
uh state representative belnap County
District 3 lonan I'm testifying today as
a member of the
public
in almost every circumstance programs
set up by the
government that are to help so-called
disadvantaged groups such as the poor or
the needy or in this case low wage
workers almost always have the exact
opposite effects on those groups that
their well-intended sponsors hope
for in the case of minimum wage as with
any bad legislation it stems from two
groups the special interest groups such
as in this case trade or labor unions
and the well-intentioned do gooders who
believe they are helping people by
enacting a law that proclaims nobody
will get paid less than
$22.50 per hour when in reality this
bill will do nothing of the
kind what you are in fact doing is
ensuring that people whose skills
education or experience do not justify
that kind of a wage will be unemployed
if a person comes to an employer for a
job say in the construction field has
little to no skills and is worth perhaps
$10 per hour to clean up the job site
assist with manual labor all while
learning to be a carpenter or a backhoe
operator HB 107 would now make it
illegal for that employer to hire that
person unless the employer was willing
to engage in charity moreover the person
misses out on the opportunity to learn
on the job skills knowledge and
experience that someday May indeed make
that employee highly valuable and worth
more
money we now will have created a weak
and inefficient Workforce while
establishing a permanent class of
welfare WS of the
state this law would require employers
to discriminate against people with low
skills education or experience this is
by definition institutional
discrimination and would harm the very
people that's supposed to to hurt in
closing we all would like to and I
emphasize here earn more money however
it is clear that HB 107 will would
legalize discrimination against the good
people of New Hampshire by their
government as well as producing
crippling restrictions on our business
Community as thus I must urge this
committee to declare HV 107 inexpedient
to legislate there is no place in this
state for discrimination
much less be it imposed by this
government Upon Our citizens thank you
Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you I have a few hands
up so give me a couple minutes I'll call
everyone here uh
representative uh agent thank you Mr
chairman I thank the member for taking
the question um as a quick point of
clarification I depend on supporting 5
not this one but this is a more generic
question based on uh early parts of
teson
um do you support the existence of even
a
$725 an hour no follow follow thank you
um so if an employer was to very
literally
A1 do you think that should
be I I missed the very last part of that
if if an employer was to offer a one
dollar and hour position do you think
be uh yeah it's it's still a free
job okay any for the followup
Representative
no I see a online I think I did I see
representative Bard I know you you want
to ask a question or you want to testify
on 5117 which youve supported either way
you can do both if you'd like oh no I I
I want a
question you're recognized for for a
question
recognize buard you are ready y
recognize for okay thank you very much
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for taking my
question uh do you feel that an employer
has any
responsibility to make sure that his or
her
question I feel that it is the employees
responsibility to seek the skills the
knowledge
or the
experience to be able to command a
living
wage oh follow up representative buard
follow up uh uh thank you very much uh
Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative for taking my follow-up
question thank you um what about the
employer or the
employee that is working to three jobs
just to survive how are they going to be
getting the training or going to
hole there are many Avenues available um
I'm such a
person uh I used to be a
musician as you can imagine musicians
don't always make a lot lot of money at
all um while doing that my
family uh was starting and as such at
the exact same time my wife and
I both decided to go back to school to
get educations so we had a toddler we
were both working jobs and we were both
going to school at night I ended up
getting two degrees one of them in
education my wife got one in the
um medical
field and uh we're okay now so I I think
it's it's uh on the person and uh what
it is that they would like to do there
are plenty of avenues available to
improve
yourself thank you for the question and
thank you for answering I see
representative kahill has his hand
raised your rep your
recognize for a question uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question uh I I I'm glad
that you uh you and your wife were able
to work and and take care of your
toddler and become educated I wonder
what sort of wages you were earning
process was there a minimum wage or or
were you able to get uh a high wage than
seven and a quarter an
hour I you you broke up a little bit in
the middle of that
represent sorry uh let me try
again uh what sort of wages were you
earning uh when you were in this you
know education and uh you know
furtherance of your of your uh situation
we were both working for minimum wage or
was it a little bit higher than that uh
we were working I would assume a little
um my wife was uh still in the uh
medical field she was just um in the
administration of of that so she was
running an office and I again like I
said was a a musician but I also was a h
Service employee so um I was on tips so
it basically it depended on how well I
did my job whether or not I made money
or
not um followup follow up representative
yeah I I think that I think the tip part
also reflect was determined by the uh
generosity of the
customer uh which you sometimes a good
job doesn't always yield a good
tip just one more followup what what do
you play representative Huff uh guitar
guitar I'm a bass player and uh our
chairman is a reformed drummer I play
the drum we could have a band right here
I think so the labor band the labor band
any other questions for the
representative or the
speaker seeing none online any here in
the committee room see none I'm GNA move
on to the next um speaker I only have
one so Christina after this you let me
know if there's any others Henry Vu New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association are you with
us Big
H hello can you hear me yes we can okay
great um thank you very much uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Henry veu and
I'm here on behalf of the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association uh
testifying on uh House Bill 107 and I
won't uh I don't really want to get into
uh the hourly rate and what that should
be I think because that is probably
largely going to be be decided on the
federal level I think uh you know we all
see that there's a move for federal
legislation I think with a makeup down
there there's probably a pretty good
chance that uh the the wage will
probably get increased on the federal
level and as you know the state of New
Hampshire has to follow the Federal
which sets a floor so um you know I
don't think uh you know there's a lot of
uh good in US debating what it should be
here because I think for a large uh
degree it'll probably be decided on the
federal level but I do want to address
um a section of current law uh that we
would like to have uh addressed and in
fact I I emailed the committee yesterday
uh two attachments uh one attachment is
a bill that uh Senator Bradley uh has
filed uh it hasn't come out yet but it
is something that is to address uh the
tip wage um um in the statute right now
um the tip wage is essentially tied to
uh the minimum wage the hourly rate as
you know we don't have a state minimum
wage right now so our tip wage
essentially tied to the federal minimum
wage and for those of you that have uh
the legislation that I emailed in front
of you you will notice in statute that
it says um
the wage from the
employer that tipped employees get shall
be
45% of the hourly minimum wage um and
right now uh that is
$327 and you know when I'm talking about
minimum wage uh when I'm talking about
tipped employees tipped employees aren't
minimum wage workers they're not minimum
wage hourly workers um on average uh the
take-home is between $18 and $20 an hour
with wages uh from the employer and tips
combined I mean the bulk of what they
earn comes in tips uh but they're
considered wages uh they have to report
them as wages the employer pays the FICA
and uh the taxes on those tips as wages
so they're essentially wages and again
they're they're earning about between
$18 and $220 an hour um but in the New
Hampshire statute the minimum that um
they must get from the employer is uh
written in the statute as 45% of the
hourly range what we would like to do is
change it from um a percentage of the
minimum hourly rate to a specific number
in the statute
um the bill um that Senator Bradley has
uh would keep it at 327 per hour um I
also included a bill that was uh
introduced last year by Senator
Susi um the Senate President uh last
year and she um in her bill did
something similar um she struck out 45%
of the applicable minimum wage and she
in her bill $4 but uh the reason for
bringing that up is I think you know we
were on the same page and sort of uh
wanting to put a specific number in
statute because if the federal minimum
wage does go up to $15 let's just say
that happens um the uh minimum wage for
tipped employees would go from 327 to
675 um which is just about double uh of
what what it is now uh in many of the
restaurants that I've talked to have
said that would represent about a 40%
increase in their payroll costs uh which
it's got to come out of someplace and
would probably be you know the the
increase in uh uh menu prices um so uh
what we would like to do and would again
it's a Senate Bill uh it's going to be
discussed in the Senate we hope to get
some bipartisan support and that it
comes to the house in the spring um so
you very well may be dealing uh with
that bill again it doesn't have a bill
number yet it's still in LSR um but I
just wanted to give you a heads up uh
that the issue of uh the tip wage in New
Hampshire statute is something that
we're going to want to have a discussion
with you and your committee and it will
probably come in the form of Senator
Bradley's bill which you will get after
crossover uh and we'll be discussing the
you you uh in the spring so that's it um
I'm happy to take any questions if
anybody has
any do I see any questions from any
members
online I do not see any hands anyone any
in the uh community room uh
representative
seaworth thank you for your testimony
and your update on the um proposed
Senate bill I did have a question um if
you have knowledge on this the other New
England states are
we an outlier in that our tipped wage is
done as a percentage is do other states
do it that way or do um our neighbors
all tend to have a fixed rate for
uh thank you for the question we are an
outlier uh the other states uh have uh
basically fixed uh mounts in the statute
which the legislature can revisit as
they would you know anytime they wanted
to revisit uh the minimum hour Le um but
the unique way we have it crafted now uh
just it will decimate restaurants if it
remains a percentage of the hourly so we
would like but thank you for your
question we'd like to to uh to do what
Most states do and have a specific U
amount of
Statute thank you representative kahill
thank you Mr chairman uh and M mru I
know we've we've wandered off the topic
of the bill at hand but since we've done
that and we're talking about outliers
isn't it true that New Hampshire is an
outlier and that we allow the
restaurants to retain 3% of the tax they
collect from their customers
um so that's an issue you're talking
about the rooms of males tax so that's
the restaurants for those not familiar
with what uh representative K is talking
about this is an issue that comes up in
the house w means committee so the
restaurants are responsible for
collecting the rooms of meals tax for
the state um there is a provision in the
law that if they
remitted by uh the 15th of the B day of
the following month they get to retain
3% of that as a commission for
collecting the tax um and uh other
states have different amounts um but New
Hampshire does have 3% um you know uh
for people that use credit cards uh
going to restaurants um which is the
majority people now uh there's a credit
card fee charge uh uh there's a
percentage charge on on that so it no
one none of the restaurants are making
money on it they're basically just
covering their cost for collecting the
tax for the
state but that's that's an issue for the
ways of need follow followup there a
followup uh Mr ve would you U we're
having a hard time you're getting could
you uh off a little closer to your
receiver or please is this
better representative uh kale go ahead
with your question uh yes uh Mr veu uh I
know the IRS is going to be U processing
returns uh in a couple of a week or so
do you suppose we'll get a discount if
we pay our pay our taxes early by the
15th
uh well uh um you know
the individual taxes I think are a
little different uh from uh the tax that
uh the ruins of meal stack for instance
which The Operators collect for the
state I think uh for individuals and you
know they don't retain anything for
their business taxes that they pay uh
obviously uh so I think it's kind of an
apples to oranges comparison that you
have rather than Apples to Apples right
well thank you very much for your
patience thank you representative kill
any additional questions for the
speaker seeing none um Christina do we
have any additional people wishing to
speak on this
bill yes we have Bruce Burke who um
signed up to
testify
speak Mr berky I am here sorry about
that Mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you very much for your
time this afternoon I know you've had a
a long day so I'll try to keep this as
brief as possible as I speak to both
house bills 107 and
517 um I represent the national
Federation of Independent
Business Nationwide organization but
here in New Hampshire we represent more
than 1,000 New Hampshire small
businesses and they oppose these
increases in minimum wage and we incre
we oppose them for a variety of reasons
unintended consequences is the biggest
reason if these
rates more than double and triple in the
case of
107 fewer jobs will be available fewer
hours for employees will be
available and perhaps fewer businesses
will be available and these this will be
hurting the very employees that these
Advocates are trying to
help and why does this happen it happens
because mandated actions minimums like
the earlier bill on on mandating sick
leave are are taking place to infringe
upon the free
market under the parameters of these
bills an employee will earn more per
hour but may end up earning less per
week because the individual's hours have
been
cut small businesses need to balance
their budgets every day it is important
to recognize that each dollar increase
for a full-time minimum wage job can
cost that employer over $2,200 per year
you have the wage you have Medicare
taxes and you have unemployment comp
taxes plus workers comp
insurance therefore these bills will
cause approximately depending on which
Bill and what increase between five and
employers it is important to remember
that the minimum wage was never intended
to to support entire
families it was designed to be a
draining wage it was designed to ensure
a a
base the proponents of 517 I applaud
them because they recognize the true
intent of a minimum wage through the new
paragraph at the end of the bill that
would establish a youth minimum
wage in any discussions going forward
this Vision needs to continue to be a
part of that
conversation prior to the pandemic
reports showed that the lower
25% of paid workers were seeing their
wages rise faster than those in the top
25% and that was occurring because of
the competition by employers for
employees there are so
few really the statistics show that
there are so few minimum wage employees
in the Hampshire and in reality those
statistics are
representing those workers that your
previous speaker just spoke to it's it's
those in the hospitality world who are
getting tips and and earning much more
than the minimum
wage so starting wages in New Hampshire
are as high as they have ever been and
they are far above the minimum wage a
strong economy helped by not raising
business taxes last year
um the year before as well is helping
all employees and businesses I mean look
at New Hampshire where 4% unemployment
during this pandemic we are in a good
position here in the Northeast let's not
Crush that we oppose these bills and we
want to allow New Hampshire's markets to
grow jobs and grow wages so businesses
can continue to succeed thank you Mr
chairman and I'll try and address any
questions you or your committee May
have thank you any questions in the uh
uh um yeah in the committee
room seeing none any
online
folks seeing none Christine is that the
last
speaker um we have Rich gulla
um signed up to speak I'd like to close
House Bill
107 and leave the remaining bill for 517
FN unless this individual is speaking on
the
um because I don't want people to keep
saying oh well they're talking about
that one and I was hold I was hanging
out for 517 so I'll just jump on here
and plus I would really like to get
something to eat since I have not eaten
since last night 8:00 and I'm going to
turn it over to uh repres uh
representative seaworth um
representative kale you have a
question it was just that I was going to
suggest you turn things over to the
capable representative seaworth so you
can get a
bite thank you I'm going to do that um
this gentleman um what is his name again
please you'd like to
testify Mr
gulla
Christina yes
representative I'm sorry I didn't hear
what is the gentleman's name who'd like
to speak on House Bill 107 uh so he's
actually not available uh I apologize he
was earlier we have a couple of other
hands raised um but I'm not sure um what
your your plan is if you wanted to hear
additional
testimony all right I'm going to do the
following I'm going to take these two
individuals I'm not going to take any
more after this I'm going to take these
two individuals if they'd like to speak
on the $22 50 Cent if they going to
speak of the other one I'm going to
close this hearing and open the last one
on 517 since that has um a lot of
different things in it and this one's
just simply raising it to 2250 so uh
what is the gentleman's the first
gentleman's name so um actually I have a
Sherry
Frost Miss Frost is scheduled to speak
on the next bill okay um so uh if she'd
wait I will do that um she is he's
signed up to testify on uh House Bill
tieran
I yes it does um I'm going to turn the
uh hearing over to representative
seaworth and representative seaworth you
dude and I would I would recognize
representative um so just to I'm going
to follow along with what the uh
chairman said that i' we'd like to take
these last two speakers if they still
want to speak and if they want to speak
on the 2250 Bill if not we'll move on to
the next bill so representative Frost if
you um representative Frost is a
co-sponsor of this bill 107 so if uh you
would like to speak on this
bill well she put her hand down I think
um and the the last speaker Mr
Tiernan yes
him thank you I'm not the political
director with sea um thank you for
recognizing me I just want to make sure
that uh president Rich gulla who's not
on right now can speak to the next bill
if if that's all right with the
committee we will go through everyone
who wants to speak with the next bill
you and then the last person that I have
I apologize was on the list is uh
infinity
sanderfer
okay
um did
that I can send you the updated file
afterwards n r f
r um go ahead you recognize to speak on
the 2250 Bill be one
hello my name is infinity sanderfer and
I live in West Lebanon um I am
representing myself as a poor person I
last year made $15 an hour working
full-time and I still qualified for cash
assistance I have one child he's five
years old um I've been working in child
care um or resfit care type jobs for
most of my life and for most of my life
I have not made a living wage um we like
to throw around a lot of different terms
I feel like uh minimum wage has an idea
tied to it that a living wage does not
um and I can say that you're right a
minimum wage is not capable of
supporting a family but I as a single
person should be capable of supporting a
family um especially doing jobs that are
important to the community um during the
pandemic we saw a lot of folks that make
um far below living wages being
considered essential workers
and
um sorry
um we we talk about how you know
somebody at McDonald's shouldn't
necessarily make as much as a CEO um but
I'm not really sure why somebody's sweat
at a drive-thru is worth less than
somebody sweat in an office um I feel
that you know we throw around these
terms in hopes that we can kind of get
around the issue of this is a moral
issue being able to survive is a moral
issue this is not you know worrying
about somebody's pocket along the lines
these are people who are showing up at
food banks and on assistance and
incapable of taking care of themselves
if you pay people a a living wage then
the cost of insurances and doctor's
bills goes significantly down um you can
save money in a lot of other areas just
by providing people enough money to
survive um I am in full support of a
living wage um which we know is about 22
to $23 an hour um and I
really don't understand how the argument
can get from you know the morality of
survival to um you know pocketbooks
these are two different conversations um
Rich get rich literally off of the sweat
of the folks working at Walmart
McDonald's um and and these huge
companies that don't pay living wages
while Rich folk continue to get rich why
um is there such a huge discrepancy in
the worth of somebody's time an hours
worth of time should be an hours worth
of time regardless of what you were
doing um and I feel like that's really
um kind of important when we're talking
Hampshire thank you very much for your
testimony do we have any questions uh
for this Witness
online seeing no hands are there any
questions in the committee room
seeing none um thank you very much and
with that I will
close the hearing on HB
and um I may need help uh chairman
infantine was very quick to count off we
have a a number of pages of signin for
HB 107 and do you have the numbers on
that um Miss
[Music]
do for that particular Bill there were
223 people in
support and 41 opposed one person was
neutral all right thanks for that
help and uh with that I'll move on to
and that is HB
517 and I will first see I know
representative Schulz had other
commitments um she is the prime sponsor
of this bill so if she is available I
here excellent thank you Mr chair yes
I've been in and out of my committee
I've already cast four votes and I'm
back
um thank you so much for your time uh
labor committee I really appreciate your
stamina on this issue New Hampshire
needs a needs a raise desperately we've
had a minimum wage in the past um before
removing it and defaulting to the
federal one 725
$725 an hour is irresponsible and in all
kindness
inhumane we are a wealthy state but over
130,000 people make less than $15 an
hour in the granite state and what's
really bizarre to me on that level not
only does it make it difficult for
families but the average citizen in New
Hampshire actually supports bringing
back a New Hampshire minimum wage that
is uh much higher than 725 an hour um
hang on just a
second sorry about that um I also just
for the record want to say I also
support the other Bill the other Bill
gets closer to a living wage but in all
honesty um if you look at the MIT living
wage calculator which I know
representative Schmidt mentioned earlier
I'm GNA send a few links to a few New
Hampshire specific data from that
because it really does a great job of
showing uh What It Is by estimates uh an
actual living wage uh in most parts of
New Hampshire it is generalized though
by County so um do see that with a grain
of salt that's uh Waters it down a bit
you know comparing a an expensive place
like Portsmouth to other parts of that
County uh and it's true in pretty much
every County but anyway looking at that
uh the minimum wage of
$725 an hour uh is below the poverty
rate um and in general for the whole
state a a living wage for if you average
everywhere in New Hampshire for a family
of three one child with two parents with
one of the parents working it's uh about
$54,000 a year as a living wage that's
just for rent food the absolute Basics
that doesn't include a a cable package
it doesn't include student loans it
doesn't include expensive medical debt
it doesn't include saving for
emergencies or uh
retirement um it in all kinds of things
so I do want to Pivot and say some good
news and that is because the fight for
15 has been successful in a lot of
places in America whether it's on many
cities or states we've been able to do a
lot of interesting studies in America
that compare those economies to the ones
like ours and by the way we are in a sad
little donut here with everybody around
us paying significantly better and
having a better um Quality of Life as a
result but the good going back to the
good news we know that while for the
initial um implementation of a decent uh
raise like my bill does which starts at
over $112 an hour which puts us in a
line with our
neighbors um there is a short period a
maybe months or less where there is a
bit of an adjustment but very quickly
the economy rebounds and does very well
because the majority of money that a
low- wage worker earns is spent and put
right back into the economy
immediately and uh entrepreneurship
actually goes up contrary to what a
previous speaker was saying
if you pay people a living wage if you
pay them uh a better wage they actually
then can start jobs and can start
companies or go off on their own and
freelance and live a better wage after
that it gives them a spring off point to
do that it here's two of the more
interesting ones comparing again the
places where the fight for 15 has been
successful and the economy like ours uh
where they raised the wage it this
significant reduction in the number of
suicides in in those communities
compared to our economy and even uh a
significant decrease in unwanted
pregnancies because go figure most of
the people who earn low wages are women
and they can afford to have the babies
so I can send you the links to those
studies if you like that um I also want
to address one other point from a
previous speaker who was speaking about
this bill and the previous Bill and
talked about a training wage and I just
felt uh a little frustrated because
there's this notion that well if you
want to make more and you want to better
job you should just go get a better job
and I think that there's a real problem
with that Society um I come I the first
in my family to get a college education
but my parents were very happy to be a
baggage handler and a school secretary
and they liked their jobs they had no
desire to do anything else actually and
they were able to do that for most of
their careers and I think that it's been
true in American history that if you
want to work at a store or if you want
to work as a home care Aid or a child
care worker all of those are jobs that
tend to be very low wage in our current
economy for many people that's a calling
and I think this country needs to change
our attitude about that and go to what
Martin Luther King Jr said that all
labor has dignity every job that someone
has created in and of itself should be
seen with dignity and we should pay the
wages that should match that dignity and
not have people needing to file uh go
for government assistance when they're
working full-time I find that disgusting
I find that immoral and we have the
ability to do right by that to make sure
that instead of giving backdoor
corporate Weare to places like Walmart
who teach their employees and they're
not the only ones to go on public
assistance then they get state grants
from the state of New Hampshire um I can
get you that data and that
substantiation for a whole ton of money
and then cause a difficulty for their
workers when we know that uh there a
stigma Associated to getting Public
Assistance um I would say many low-wage
workers who have to apply for assistance
have their own inner voice of a tea
party person telling them uh what a
failure they are when in fact they
should have dignity and be paid a living
wage which is just which is fair which
is good for the economy reduces suicides
and a lot of other good things we're far
overdue to bring back in New Hampshire
uh minimum wage and if um I could go on
for much longer but I will stop my
remarks and take any questions anyone
may
have all right thank you representative
for your
testimony are there any questions for
online uh representative bushard you are
signed up to speak and are a co-sponsor
of this bill
typically you choose one side of the
table or the other oh okay so I won't
ask a question okay thank you I
question seeing none uh representative
agitant you were
recognized and I don't know if you're
close enough to Mike do you have one
you thank the representative for taking
my question um I want to
give you a quote and I'm wondering if
you can tell me who said
it okay the minimum has to go up at
least 10 federally but it has to go up
can you tell me who said
that um gonna guess Ronald
Reagan I honestly I don't
know yes would you believe me if I told
you that that was former president
Trump I I would actually yes just one
you if this is going to turn into a big
support go ahead
follow I can tell you that there are a
lot of low wage workers among the
supporters of Donald Trump so this would
actually help them that's part of my
followup um in 2020 the State of Florida
voted for President Trump uh by four and
a half percent
um at the same time the State of Florida
passed with 60% of the vote enough for a
constitutional amendment a minimum wage
of $15 an hour jumping from $8.50 an
hour to $15 an hour so do you believe
there is a possibility for a broad
bipartisan consensus on an issue like
the minimum wage I absolutely do and I
know that there has been polling in New
Hampshire
where um it was a poll in
2019 of New Hampshire voters and even
over 60% of Republican voters in New
Hampshire support bringing back a New
Hampshire minimum wage that is
significantly higher than the current
federal rate and I don't understand why
that hasn't shown up in the polling of
SE Governor but yes you're absolutely
popular all right thank you are there
other questions from in the committee
room one last opportunity from
online seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you Mr chair I
appreciate your time
committee um I will next recognize
buard
thank you Mr chairman and thank you my
fellow colleagues for taking my
testimony and support for HP
517 um I represent an economically
diverse W in Manchester and while
campaigning to represent this ward in
for the house I met
constituents that are struggling to make
ins meet even while working two to three
jobs I supported a $15 minimum wage
during our last session as well as
supporting this $15 minimum wage Bill
during this
session to make a connection in my
support of this bill with my core
beliefs in life is that I believe no one
who works 40 hours a week should
struggle to put food on their table and
pay their rent and we should be trying
to make a goal to create a living wage
in the state thank
you thank you representative are there
questions for the representative from
the committee
room seeing no questions here are there
online I see no hands so thank you for
your testimony representative thank you
still have representative frost on the
call Representative Frost you are
recognized to
speak thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Sher Frost I represent dover's Ward 4
straford
16 um as a general rule one should
expend no more than 30% of one's gross
monthly income on housing if one is a
renter that 30% should include utilities
and if one is an owner it should include
other Home Ownership costs like morgage
interest property taxes and
maintenance I've done some research and
found the average rent not including
Utilities in several towns across the
state I'd like to share with you what I
found the average rent in Manchester is
$1,431 in Dover it's
1485 in conquered it's
1225 nsha miramac and Portsmouth come in
around,
1670 Rochester Hudson Temple and Laconia
figure around 1,200 with Belmont coming
in a little lower at
1185 godown and Guilford rentals can be
had at an average of about 1150 or so
rent in Lebanon is about
$1,955 Berlin and Goram come in the
least expensive towns of those I
researched Berlin's rent is about $940
and gorm's is about
700 remember these are all figures from
rent alone and don't include any
utilities in every single one of those
towns with the exceptions of Berlin and
Goram one would have to earn at least
$20 an hour to come in at a 30%
recommendation referenced above in order
to live in Lebanon one needs to earn
closer to $34 an hour NASA and marac and
Portsmouth rent would require about $28
an hour and to live in my city of Dober
one needs to earn about $25 an hour even
living in the least expensive
communities I researched with would
require a salary of at least $113 an
hour a figure well above the current
minimum wage of
725 that's just rent that figure doesn't
cover utilities or groceries or
insurance or Transportation costs or
child care or any of the other expenses
that come with basic
survival it's my contention and I would
Hazard guess that my co-sponsors of both
of these minimum wage bills would agree
though I wouldn't Dain to put words in
their mouths that all workers deserve a
livable wage if a job needs doing the
person doing that job should be fairly
compensated and by fairly compensated I
mean they should be earning enough to
thrive in the communities where they
work we worry an awful lot about what
raising wages will do to businesses I
think it's long past time we start
asking why it is that these businesses
aren't able to pay wages that ensure
that their workers are able to live safe
and dignified lives thank
you thank you representative for your
testimony are there any questions for
the representative I'll first go
online I don't see any hands so in the
committee room representative Hub thank
you Mr
chair um my question is uh first what
was the um the hourly uh rate that you
mentioned to live in
Lebanon uh let me go back to my
notes about uh lebanon's rent is about
19955 a month
um and again I'm an English teacher so
you're welcome to check my math but I
came out at about $34 an hour just to
cover
rent follow up follow up um does anybody
Lebanon I'm sorry are you asking me if
anybody lives in Lebanon
yes I'm certain people live in Lebanon
yes thank
you uh I'll Rec recogniz representative
agan for a question thank you Mr
chairman um I appreciate the research
that the member has put into this um on
that note
um representative would you believe me
if I said that since
1968 um the buying power of the minimum
wage has dropped
31% compared to what it is today meaning
that workers earning minimum wage have
on average
$6,800 less to spend on Necessities than
those same people did doing those same
jobs 50 years
that any further questions from the
committee
room any members I missed
online seeing none thank you
representative Frost for your testimony
um I'll now go on to the next one on the
list I have the Reverend Dr Gail Kenny
uh representing herself as a member of
the public but also representing the New
Hampshire United Church Church of Christ
economic Justice
muted I don't think she
understand Reverend Kenny you appear to
yourself weit you're still muted and we
um I'm going to assume there's an issue
with your system that you may be able to
look into I'll skip ahead to the next
person on the list and we'll come back
to you
um and see if if we can hear you in a
little bit um so next up I have Maggie
Fogerty uh Lobby for the American friend
Hampshire what happened to
Christina is Miss F not see
her all right I will again come back to
her if uh she shows up before the end um
next up I would recog recognize Greg
Moore a lobbyist for Americans for
Hampshire do not see him
so I still see Reverend Kenny muted is
that at our end or at her end oh that's
at her and I left her on in case she
unmuted but she has
not okay so that's all the um people
that signed up in advance to speak I
have a few more uh that signed up after
those were generated um I have um Rich
gulla from the sea yes uh I I'd
gulla
oops just a moment
can you hear me okay yep go ahead great
um I want to thank you I'm actually
testifying on house bill7 I'm sorry I uh
had some technical difficulties and and
couldn't make it until now but good
afternoon my name is Richard gulla I am
president of the state employees
Association SEIU Local
1984 we represent the majority of state
employees as well as workers in some of
our states counties and
municipalities and again I'm speaking in
favor of house Bill 107 I'm here because
New Hampshire's low wage workers deserve
a raise I support reestablishing a
Granite State minimum wage and raising
it in order to lift up all of New
Hampshire's families the federal minimum
wage which are now stuck at without our
own has been stuck at 725 since 2009
meanwhile the cost of everything is gone
up milk bread eggs rent electricity and
believe it or not even with the recent
dip in fuel prices gasoline and Home
Heating oils are still more expensive
today than in 2009 in fact since the
1960s the minimum wage has lost almost
50% of its purchasing power the failing
value of minimum wage is hurting
thousands of New Hampshire's Working
Families and eroding the stability of
our
communities that's because contrary to
popular myth almost 90% of the impact of
minimum wage is on workers over the age
of 20 and more than 50% are women many
with
children as a store manager at one of
New Hampshire's liquor stores I have
worked personally and known many minimum
wage workers part-time clerks some
working two or three jobs to make ends
meet a mom who was working part-time for
me once told me that it wasn't her
health benefits that she wanted but more
hours so she could put more food on the
table for her five children and I cannot
begin to tell you how many young adults
I have met who were still living with
their parents and worse parents who have
been forced to live with their
children as a New Hampshire citizen I'm
frankly outraged by how many large
companies are exploiting workers and and
the state people should not be choosing
between healthc care and food workers
should not have to receive guidance on
how they apply for
assistance as part of their company's
orientation we are better than this and
as president of one of the largest
unions in the state I am determined to
change it we believe that height is
turning on this issue already we are
seeing companies large and small moving
to raise the wages of workers and
supporting an increase in the minimum
wage companies like McDonald's and Ikea
are supporting a raise of the minimum
wage and we all know that Costco has
proven that even a living wage business
model can flourish in our
economy the people are also speaking out
fast food workers are organizing in
demanding action and more than 75% of
American public support raising the
minimum wage all all across this country
coalitions are working tiously and
successfully 22 states have passed a
minimum wage higher than the federal
rate you have in front of you a
significant
opportunity the minimum wage was enacted
nearly 80 years ago by President
Roosevelt with broad bipartisan support
it has been raised over the years again
with bipartisan support because both
political parties have understood that
raising the tide lifts all
boats a minimum wage ear earner Works
$14,500 per year you have an opportunity
to change that to make it better make it
better for all of us I have been very
fortunate to work for the state of New
Hampshire and thanks to my union there
are no minimum wage jobs in our
bargaining unit but today our voices are
with the growing chorus of the public
who want the minimum wage raised it is
time to give the people of our state a
raise with that I conclude my testimony
and thank you right thank you for your
testimony um I see a question here in
the committee room for uh the witness
representative Edon thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking the
question Mr Gilla um one of the
criticisms of an increase in the minimum
wage
consistently um is that it would
obliterate jobs and raise Unemployment
uh however in my research the other
night I noticed that the u a Australia
has a minimum wage of
$19.84 an hour and they have the same
unemployment rate as the United States
uh do you think that the um line of
argument that this would be a job
Destroyer is an accurate one I'd have to
research that more I don't but I'd have
you any other questions from the
committee
online I see no hands raised so I thank
you for the testimony thank you could
you give us our next speaker
please I have Jane
Hay all
correct it appears there okay yeah it's
hay like the General
Alexander um hi there I'm just speaking
for myself I live in
Manchester and um I just think everybody
that works needs to have a living
wage um representative Frost discussed
the amount of rent that people pay Etc
and it seems obvious that 725 is just
not enough I think everyone that works
full-time deserves the Dignity of living
wage so that they don't have to depend
on any of the resources like Snap or um
food assistance or any of the other even
you know Medicaid assistance so I really
hope that you will just pass this bill
so that we can um afford everyone in New
Hampshire the Dignity of a living wage
thank you thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for this Witness
online seeing none anybody from the
committee room
thank you again for your
testimony thank you who else do we
have looks like um Dr Reverend Gail
Kenny has raised her hand so perhaps
she's available
now okay let's see if we
can um get that working re Reverend
Kenny um yes uh Mr chair and members of
the committee I apologize for that
glitch before I I live in a
technological desert in New Hampshire
and I've been listening to your uh the
Committee hearing right from its
beginning this afternoon and just at the
moment you called my name the U the
computer froze and I couldn't get back
on so anyway thank you for your patience
so for the record my name is Gail Kenny
I'm a resident of Kanan New Hampshire
and I am a pastor with the United Church
of Christ and back in um
2014 uh the United Church of Christ
which is the largest Protestant
denomination in the state and and the UC
is made up it it's all the
congregational churches that dot the
landscape from north to south east to
west in New Hampshire um but the um in
2014 this denomination passed a very
strong resolution um calling on New
Hampshire to
reinstate a state minimum wage at a rate
that was not a moral embarrassment and
and other words um a living wage and
that resolution sadly is now um 7 years
old and um and every year the um the
denomination along with his faith
Partners in many many other
denominations sort of restate and
reinforce um their their commitment or
their desire a matter of public policy
for you folks to um to reestablish a
minimum wage and make it a living wage
so uh who does this uh really affect
who's who's really um who are we dealing
with who are we talking about what are
the faces what are the names who are the
people people and I would say that as we
have lived through almost a year now of
this pandemic I have to believe that
every member of this committee at one
point or another has praised essential
workers those people who are are um
still doing Food Service who were
working as cashiers in the stores the
people who were cleaning the uh the
hospitals and nursing homes and even the
the building that you were in those of
you who are in the State House on people
that are doing home health care or still
taking care of children and on and on
and most of the uh low-wage workers in
our state at this point in time um who
are still living in poverty um even
though they're working full-time most of
them are in fact the essential workers
that we talk about and that we praise
the unfortunate thing is that praise for
those workers and lotting them and
appreciate them for what they do does
not pay their bills um so I want to uh
just address two other things really
quickly I want like to dispel a couple
of myths that have been um raised over
and over about um the um about a minimum
wage or living wage and the first is
that and this has been mentioned but I
want to reiterate it um the original
concept of a minimum wage for this
nation and for the states over 70 years
ago it was never ever ever meant to be a
training wage it was meant to be a
living wage it was meant to when um when
Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and others who um supported uh
the concept of a minimum wage in both
the house and the Senate and and across
the country they were talking about a
wage through which workers could afford
full-time workers could afford the
basics of living food clothing and
shelter and and more and again I'm sure
that every single member of this
committee is very familiar with what the
costs are uh for shelter and for food
and the basics of living in New
Hampshire and New Hampshire that also
that includes transportation and heat
Etc that you know what that costs and
and the reality is the reality is that
every single person who works full-time
in the state of New Hampshire should be
able to for those things the basics of
living in the state of New Hampshire um
and and that that should be a moral
priority I would hope for every member
of the legislature and second um it's
it's argued that um and I think we heard
this today already um in terms of I
think it was House Bill 107 that um well
you know we don't need to establish a
state minimum wage we don't need to have
a public policy for a wage flow or
public policies for living wages because
the market will provide the market will
take care of things just let the mark
the free market provide well okay so the
market provides except when it doesn't
if the market were working then every
person um who was working a full-time
job would be able to lift themselves out
of poverty and that is frankly not the
case in New Hampshire if the market
would uh were to provide then full-time
workers would not have to depend on
tax-funded
Services for food for heat for Health
Care Etc um if if the market were
working um particularly for people in
food service and hospitality and health
care and Elder Care care and janitorial
services they wouldn't continue to live
in poverty they wouldn't live a life of
of um of economic anxiety every day of
their lives um so another thing I just
want to note about this particular bill
I was fascinated by the fiscal note the
fiscal note talks about uh or it
outlines um in terms of the state that
oh my goodness if we were to raise the
minimum wage even up to that $12 Mark or
whatever just that would affect the
state because we already we pay 241
people right now below that Mark and um
and in the next tier of the raise that
would affect seven 901 workers and on
and on so my question is who are those
241 workers today that are working not
enough really to survive and are they
also on food stamps or any other kind of
support and it should be are they
essential workers what kind of service
are they providing state workers are are
sort of an essential foundation for
beloved we talk in in the church we use
the word Beloved Community but if we are
not paying workers today state workers
today enough to live on that that fiscal
note should be an embarrassment to all
of us so I just wanted to um to to
emphasize that point as well um I just
want to say something quickly about in
reference back to house bill 501 and to
just minimum the concept of minimum wage
overall there is a a a history professor
at Dartmouth who is nationally known
actually internationally known for her
work on on wages Analise Dr Analise
orleck and she wrote a book two years
ago we are all fast food workers now and
the title of that book comes from when
she was interviewing adjunct faculty who
said you know what we we're we're fast
food workers now that's what we make or
even less than what fast food workers
make and in her research she has found
that um adjunct faculty members were
among among the most easily economically
exploited and some of the lowest paid uh
people in the workforce on an hourly
basis so that's just I that's a moral
embarrassment too so overall I know
you'll hear from other people and you've
already heard excellent testimony with
facts and figures but essential
workers deserve in the state of New
Hampshire deserve to essentially live
and that should be a basic public policy
of the State of New Hampshire so I urge
you I implore you um with all the the
moral strength I can muster um to find
this bill ought to
pass thank
youon um are there any questions for
online seeing no hands are there any
questions from the committee
room seeing none thank you again for
your
time um do we have any any other uh
people waiting
eluni missel honei you recognized to
speak thank you chair can you hear me
yes awesome my name is Asma alonei and
I'm the movement politics director for
rights and democracy New Hampshire uh I
actually wanted to speak in favor of
House Bill 107 for a livable wage
because that's what we really need to
support livable wages but since we did
move on um I am here to speak in support
of HB 517 because it's the next best
thing and certainly not enough um also I
just want to also address representative
Greg Hugh um uh representative I
actually live in Lebanon I moved to
Lebanon in August and I would not have
moved to Lebanon without three
individuals who are paying rent in uh
our our apartment so just wanted to say
that our rent is $1
19994 I also have friends who are
sharing homes in Lebanon as well so not
really sure why you asked if there were
people living in Lebanon because uh yes
there are people living in Lebanon and
yes there are people struggling to keep
a roof over their heads who live there
as well so just wanted to share that so
back to the bill um this is certainly
not a complicated bill um and I'm
certain that none of you here are going
to be okay with the current 725 24 the
uh current minimum wage uh and so I
expect that all of you will uh do the
proper thing and and definitely vote in
support of this bill uh this is
definitely a no-brainer and I trust
again that you'll vote the right way but
I do wanted to share a testimony from a
restaurant because we were talking about
small business um and the restaurant is
called ganos and it's also in Lebanon
and this is what they gave us to share
uh with this legislative body um and
they gave me this last session uh this
is a response towards the argument that
this will hurt small businesses and
basically they said um quote Dear Sir
Madame I am writing to express our
support for the concept of raising the
minimum wage to a livable wage our own
minimum wage in our kitchen is
effectively $13 per hour with the
average wage of an experienced cook
between 15 and $16 per hour we currently
pay non-tipped employees such as host as
little as $111 per hour but it would not
be crippling if we were increased to
$13 our tipped employees average a
combined wage of hourly wages and tips
of at least $13 per hour for busers in
similar positions and our servers
average $15 per hour or more with some
earning significantly more keeping the
tipped employee wage at 327 with the
exception that their combined wage to
include tips would equal $13 per hour
would not impact Us in any way Maria and
I believe that the work that is done by
our employees is worthy of a livable
wage and while we understand that
increasing the minimum wage um we may
have to increase our overall wages over
time we do also believe that an overall
wages increase in our state there will
be more money being pumped into the
local economy we also believe that when
people when possible it is better to
offer a livable wage and to encourage
the Dignity of rewarding work than to
otherwise supplement family incomes
through government programs by ensuring
Fair wages we would hope to see a
decrease in these programs over time or
at least the amount of time that
individuals and families spend
benefiting from programs before becoming
self-supporting and so um yeah I just
wanted to share this uh testimony with
you and and just to to share that small
businesses um that uh that understand
that when we pay pay workers livable
wages it's going to benefit all of us
and and the fact that we're relying on
restaurants to do that the free market
as they would call it is very
problematic because then some um
employers will pay their employees
livable wages While others don't and
that won't benefit the economy the way
um we were talking about pumping money
into the economy that that'll only work
if everyone is paying their employees a
livable wage and that way we have
everyone getting money and able to um uh
uh spend because obviously research has
shown that people that make more spend
more and of course I'm talking about the
average um uh resident or a Community
member I'm not talking about
Millionaires and and billionaires but
the average um uh Community member does
spend when they make
more thank you thank you for your
testimony could I ask you to spell your
name for the committee records please
absolutely um it's a smat a as in apple
S as in Sam m as in Mary a as in apple
and the last name um is el honei e as in
Edward L as in Larry H as in Henry n as
in Nancy I and
Igloo thank you very much thank you um
are there any questions for this speaker
first online any
hands I don't see any anyone from the
committee room have a
question seeing none thank you again for
your
testimony do we have someone else
waiting
stob all right Miss St you are
speak hi everybody can you hear me yes
yeah um yeah thank you so much for um
giving me the opportunity to address the
committee regarding the minimum wage
bills um my name is Kathy Al and I live
in
Manchester um and this is a really very
important issue we have a lot of people
in Manchester who work for low wages and
um they really are counting on you to
help them live better lives the last
time the minimum wage was raised in New
Hampshire was in September of
2008 um every other New England state
has raised the minimum wage for its
workers mostly by legislation um and in
Maine it was a ballot initiative I sent
my testimony VI email because there's a
lot of numbers and I wanted to make sure
that uh you had something to refer to um
looking back at
20110 um the minimum wage in the New
England states raised from ranged from a
low of 725 in New Hampshire to a high of
$825 in Connecticut so there was a range
there but they were all pretty much in
the same ballpark um today Massachusetts
has the highest minimum wage at
$13.50 and the lowest minimum wage in
New England outside of New Hampshire is
$11.50 and we remain at
$725 an hour um that's just that that is
really having a negative impact on
working people in our economy um you
know I've heard a lot of excuses for not
raising the minimum wage and I'd like to
address a couple of them um the first
one is that no one actually makes 725 an
hour um you know minimum wage is not um
it's not an absolute thing it's it's
kind of like it's not a microeconomic
thing it's a macroeconomic thing and
raising the minimum wage is like kind of
like releasing a valve so you open it up
a little bit um you raise the minimum
wage and a bunch of money floods into
the economy and that circulates around
and that provides stimulation and that
enables you to keep raising the minimum
wage um and it's true that there are
very few people in Manchester making 725
an hour but because we have such a low
floor it has hampered wage growth for
other New Hampshire workers around the
state um for example we have
58,300 this these statistics are from
the um um new New Hampshire Department
of Employment Security
elmi um document um we have and it says
that we have 58,000 food service workers
and their average starting wage is $910
an hour the median wage is $123 an hour
which means that half of those 58,000
people are making less than $12 an hour
which is significantly less than a lot
of the minimum wages in um other states
um we have
21,500 Cashers in the state um in their
um average starting wage is $99.90 an
hour the median wage is
1153 um those are essential workers if
those people didn't come to work we
would have all starved to death by now
um we also have home alads who are
starting at 1123 and childcare workers
starting at 952 and janitors at
$11.13 an hour and we have those are
essential workers those are the people
who have been keeping things going for
us and they are making very low wages um
and they should be able to live with
dignity um the economic policy Institute
estimates that there are 153,000 New
Hampshire workers who would benefit from
raising the minimum wage to $15 an hour
the other argument that I hear is that
it'll cause prices to go up well um
prices have been going up uh since
2008 um housing costs for example have
increased I'm using New Hampshire
lowincome housing uh Coalition
statistics which are a little bit
different than the um numbers that uh
representative Frost had but um you know
in 2008 a two-bedroom apartment in New
Hampshire was
$1,044 per month and in 200 20 they
listed as um
$1,218 and it's higher in a lot of other
places for example Lebanon or Rockingham
County they have very high rents um so
um you know so prices are going up and I
think anybody who's been to the grocery
store recently also knows that um
because you know food prices have also
gone up ex a lot during this um pandemic
um the other argument is that um if you
raise the minimum wage it's going to
crash the economy H hamper recovery um
you only have to look at our neighboring
states to see that that's not the case
in 2017 Maine raised their minimum wage
from $7.50 to
$9 um income for the lowest paid workers
increased by the greatest amount since
2001 um an estimated 10,000 children
were lifted out of poverty and in March
of 2018 the unemployment reached its
lowest rate in 40 years they raised
their minimum wage to $10 in 2018 $11 in
2019 and $12 in 2020 and employment
rates um remain below um 4% until the
pandemic and I don't know how the
recovery will go um I suspect that
having tens of thousands of underpaid
workers who are unable to save for an
emergency is going to make it really
difficult for families to recover to pay
back rent the credit card debt that
they've incurred um since they've been
out of work um what I do know is that
raising the minimum wage has been an
important economic stimulus tool since
the Great Depression um the last time
the federal government raised the
minimum wage was during a Great
Recession it helps the lowest paid
workers meet their needs and infuses
cash into the economy and it gets it
circulating through big bit um through
business businesses big and small um
another argument that I hear is that um
other states have income taxes and
that's why they have to have higher
wages and it's true that New Hampshire
does not have an income tax but our
wages are so low much lower than minimum
wage in earners in other states um that
um you know it really does it really
doesn't matter um Maine has a 5.8%
income tax up to $44,000 a year and net
income after state tax is applied will
still be
$145 an hour Massachusetts has a flat
tax of 5% and the net income after taxes
applied is still
$12.83 which is a lot more than than
than our low-wage workers are making in
New Hampshire I mean I could do the
other states but I think you know you
get the idea um I'd also like to um take
a minute to talk about tipped wages um
you know um I've often heard people talk
about oh um how much money their servers
make by serving up the $13 hamburgers
and indeed um I'm curious to know where
that $18 an hour um figure um came from
because when I look at the LMI report it
says that for waiters and waitresses the
average wage starting wage is
$8.7 an hour the u mean wage is $13.30
an hour and the median is $9.97 so I
would be curious to know where those
numbers are coming from but when I go
out to a restaurant that $13 hamburger
does not cost me $13 I tip it 20% so
that means that I pay
$15.60 and then you add the 9% room in
meals tax and the total cost of the
$16.77 um if there aren't people that
can come in to to to pay
$16.77 cents for a burger um or somebody
comes in and eats that burger and
doesn't leave a tip then the employer
only has to make pay my server $725 an
hour for her time and that's not enough
to feed her family and keep a roof over
their heads you know and then I also
will have to fit foot the bill for the
subsidies you know the reality is that
tipped workers and the reality for
consumers you know it's a broken system
and and it needs to be
fixed you know it cost it it requires
just as much energy for somebody to
bring me an English muffin and a coffee
if I'm not that hungry as it does for
them to bring me you know a $40 steak
and um they deserve you know that work
has dignity because I really appreciate
them refilling my coffee cup and I in
those occasions I do try to tip more
than
20% um because you know if my bill is
that low that it's just really not not
worth it for them um the bottom line is
that while New Hampshire is low known to
have this low poty rate on paper the
reality is that there are thousands of
people who are struggling an estimated
47% of people in the state are rent
burdened which means they spend more
than 50% of their of 30% of their income
on housing um some people spend as much
as 50% of their inome income on housing
um you know this body has the ability to
determine um that the New Hampshire
Advantage is something that helps
corporations make profits or that helps
people who live here make a decent life
for themselves and and I think that
that's New Hampshire is a great place to
live and I think raising the minimum
wage would help more people be able to
do that um thank you thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for
this Witness
online I see no hands anybody from the
committee
room seeing none thank you
again do we have other people waiting to
up uh we had a question from the
committee room how many hands do you see
now uh two two more hands all right
thank you uh Miss Sears you are
recognized to
speak hi and thank you uh this is Amanda
Sears uh director of the campaign for
familyfriendly economy um I wanted to
testify in support of this bill um and
just to simplify it just to say that
when jobs don't pay enough um working
people can't pay their bills um and uh
that's not a sustainable um way for
people to live in this state and what
happens often is that um then working
people turn to public assistance to meet
their basic needs um even before the
pandemic one-third of recipients of cash
assistance benefits um from the tanif
program and 36% of recipients of food
stamp benefits in New Hampshire are
working families New Hampshire um this
is pre pandemic um and I think it's
probably only worse but but just to say
that these numbers are pre-pandemic
numbers New Hampshire is one of the
states with the highest percentages of
Public Assistance funds um with over 60%
of those funds going to working families
so we often think of Public Assistance
going to people who are not working but
in fact 60% of our Public Assistance
funds in New Hampshire go to Working
Families um and these programs provide
vital support to to these Working
Families um and they need that support
because their employers are paying them
less than livable wages and that's a
hidden social cost of low wage work that
the rest of us um are all covering for
for those employers who choose to pay
less than livable wages to their
employees um so just um wanted to add
our voice in support of this bill and
thank you very much for the time thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions for this witness from the
committee
question thank you again for your
testimony thank you
next hand is
Holt Mr
Holt you're
recognized hello can you hear me
yes thank you very much I am uh just
calling in on behalf of myself uh from
summersworth New Hampshire um what I
wanted to address was a previous
statement regarding um the fact that
this was a a going to be basically um
causing someone that is only worth
$725 an hour to be unemployed uh that is
a
bogus uh perspective to to look at there
there's no foundation for that um the
basically whatever someone who is doing
the the most basic work if they are
working fulltime uh for a um for a week
they need to be able to to uh afford the
basic necessities of life rent food uh
shelter Etc um it is totally objective
and and farcical to say that someone is
only worth $725 an hour I would love to
have see anybody uh do some of these
jobs from uh being a ditch digger all
day long to uh working at a fast food
restaurant Etc uh there is a lot of work
involved
but the basis really that saying 725 is
then going to um cause these people to
be unemployed it's it's actually really
ridiculous because the state and
government has already recognized that
people can't live on this so these
people are actually being um they're
having to go for government assistance
which is almost like another job having
to go through the loopholes in order to
receive that assistance
um and that is being sub so so it ends
up that the employer is being subsidized
by uh the rest of the community uh
rather for for doing something that uh
they should actually be paying for
themselves um so again it is totally
objective there's there's no standing to
say that someone is not worth 725 an
hour that's really insulting the basis
really needs to be on what would be the
minimum for someone to live which is
exactly the intent of the minimum wage
uh which is also lied about
continuously um so again we need to make
sure that we actually have a living wage
for all people uh and that way uh people
can live in dignity uh thank you very
much thank you for your testimony are
there any questions for this witness
from the committee
room seeing none anybody
online seeing none thank you again um
are there any other hands from people
who wanted to testify on this bill but
did not yet get a chance I have one more
Viola all right Viola
and I believe we spoke to you last week
could you refresh for us your last
yes we can hear you um you've just muted
yourself okay great uh sorry about that
I'm using my phone for this um good
afternoon members of the House committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak uh for the record my name is Bola
Kim and I'm here
representing uh the granite state
organizing project we are a Grassroots
nonpartisan institution that brings
Faith labor and Community groups to work
towards um a just World basically and
and I'm here to express my support for
HB 107 along with um HP
517 I submitted a written testimony for
HP 517 so if it's okay I'd like to speak
on HB
107 um if the minimum wage had kept uh
Pace with the productivity grow uh from
1938 when the minimum wage was
established today you would be more than
$24 an hour um and that that that
analysis was done by a group called
Center for economic and policy research
um but instead our minimum wage has
really stayed the same at $725 an hour
in the meantime food prices have risen
year after year rent has gone up
healthcare costs but nothing uh has been
done about our minimum W in the State uh
so we should be asking ourselves why is
it okay that we allow such a system
uh that continues to squeeze working
people um this body and our entire legis
body in newshire has an opportunity to
pass policies such as this and uh
minimum wage bills Bally that will
benefit both workers and local
businesses um I know our previous
speakers have quoted different numbers
and I would like to really uh again
share um the cost of living here and put
that into reality um the national law
Income Housing Coalition did an analysis
and study and found out that uh for a
person to afford a two-bedroom
apartments in New Hampshire they would
have to earn at least $23 an hour um and
if that person was working at $725 an
hour they had to put in 129 hours a week
to afford the two modest bedroom
apartments um and so that is the reality
of what workers in Hampshire are going
through um there's another uh a lot of a
lot has been said about calculators
there's one by the economic policy
Institute uh it's called a family budget
calculator I encourage all of you to
look at that and look at what people in
your uh counties need to actually
survive and an example of that is if
there's one working adult with one child
in Coast County they need to be making
at least 50,000 a year or over 4,000 a
month to pay for basic needs such as
food housing child care and
transportation and other assists that we
need to survive in comparison a similar
family that lives in hillsbor County
would need about
$61,000 annually or over $5,000 monthly
and when you calculate that it
translates to $24 an hour at least in Co
County and about $29 in hillsbor County
so I spoke with a worker today who I was
hopy would be on this call to share
their story um and he told me that he
has to drive from Manchester to
Massachusetts because he gets paid over
$15 over there um he can't get the same
pay here so he would rather he would
rather not commute but even with the
cost of gas and the time that he he puts
him to drive back and forth he still
makes better money in Massachusetts than
here
uh we did hear about um how increasing
the minimum wage really affects
businesses uh and a lot of speak has
really mentioned this earlier we know
that by raising the wages uh people have
higher incomes and with higher incomes
comes more stending powerful workers um
and we know during this pandemic it's
been very difficult for small businesses
um but what we should be doing we should
be focusing on making sure that we bring
in demand for goods and services in our
state so that people are spending money
and that money is helping really um
stimulate the economy um the businesses
that shut down were mostly take care um
to slow down the spread of coid 19 uh
but that also came due to reduced demand
for goods and services because people do
not have money to spend so if we're
thinking of helping businesses we should
be thinking of other options like
helping businesses with rent subsidies
learning programs but keeping the
minimum wage at $725 an hour is not the
solution um again I submitted by
testimony for HB
517 I would like to add this committee
to support HB 107 and hb5 17 and vote
out to pass thank you so much for your
time thank you for your testimony any
questions for this witness in the
committee anyone
online thank you again
again uh any remaining
hands no that is all I have seeing none
um I have just over 200 signed up ahead
of time 189 in support 13 opposed two
neutral and with that I will close the
hearing on
miss uh just a few
announcements oh you have to chair all
nice and warm ran just a few
announcements folks um I did receive a
phone call I did speak last night with
Senator um Becky wattley and um she
would like the lactation Bill 231 I
believe that we
heard um it she'd rather not um have it
retained you feel they the bill they're
working on in the Senate is much more
detailed and is um hits all the points
has been um reviewed and worked on by a
vast majority of of groups please feel
free to
um verify that she did speak with
representative Abel uh and explain that
the same thing uh that that's what she
would like um sure if you have not heard
by now the the plan of the uh speaker is
to meet on the 24th the 25th in session
in Bedford uh people have asked me if
there's going to be any remote and I
have been told there is not I do not
have all the details I assume they will
be out with the calendar which I just
tried to get online and was not
there um um for those details uh we are
having exec session please let me know
if you will not be here I already know
of one of our members that will not be
here next Thursday so we can EXA these
things there are a number of minor uh um
amendments to some of the bills that I
think we're all in favor of but it was
through some of the conversation that
they might be tweaked representative
brudy I would appreciate if you talk to
representative seaworth off offline
about the amendment you'd like um to
present on one of those bills make sure
they're all
into um um Heather so she has a copy of
them and uh to each one of your fellow
members so when we do have executive
session they can be brought up please
understand amendments are only allowed
in executive session on positive motions
bills so if the first motion is ought to
pass then amendments can be brought if
the first motion is inexpedient to
legislate amendments can't be
brought um I don't like playing the game
that who's going to throw the first one
out first so uh you know if you uh
um really have an amendment on something
um let's make sure we do it the correct
way so we don't have any uh hurt
feelings and sour faces here in labor
because we don't do that here um we not
we may not like the final vote but
that's I don't like
to too old to play uh parliamentary
games with everybody we're all going to
do it the right way in my opinion um so
suan like to take a point of uh Personal
Privilege um I think we should uh
continue the tradition of having the
chair sing Happy Birthday to anyone who
has a birthday on a uh uh on a Daye for
uh committee meetings and uh today it
happens to be Tim susi's birthday so
take it away Mr
chairman well why don't you lead us in
the
song and I will
join never I have never heard of this
tradition happy birthday
[Music]
to go to Longhorn tonight get a free
piece
buy thank you represent anyone
else thank you very much for your
patience this morning guys I know
there's some long days here we have
another one next Thursday and then we're
really getting down we have three bills
to he and we're going to try to exact
over half of our bills um so and then
we'll have another meeting uh probably
after that hopefully we can get this
done the first Thursday in March with
our our our bills all
right know how to get in touch with me
is that a question yes um I I was
looking at the email that you sent with
the number of H bills that we're going
to exec next week and I was looking also
at the calendar and it seemed like the
calendar had um several additional bills
um so um if you could just check that
out like we don't want to prep for bills
that we're not actually going to exec so
if you could just double check that and
let us know if uh um if if I'm correct
and the lists don't match if you could
let us know which list to
use use the calendar please what
occurred honestly is I tried to get that
thing out first thing Wednesday morning
to help with um Heather and her schedule
so it wasn't doing it at 12:00 in the
afternoon and as I kept reading my stuff
and getting emails from all of you
responding to some of my things oh
forgot Brian's last bill we had to put
in the calendar oh I guess this one's
going to be okay I can pull an amendment
on this one it's going to be okay and so
I added them with uh Heather and then
she made those final changes so my email
was to just out of courtesy to let you
folks know what was going on but please
go by the calendar thank
you all right folks have a good evening
be safe thank
you